you're illegally required to comply with
u.s children okay
starting some of the videos
okay we are live
toito okay yeah and cheers
cheers cheers man
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to another
friday arena but before that we have the
meadow arena as usual
and uh oh yeah for some reason yeah
we're still seeing uh
uh we're still seeing uh twitch uh
twitch alerts but it's okay
they are without sound so i i guess it's
okay it is a bit weird
uh but i i still haven't figured out how
to turn them off but at least they are
without sound so
hello everyone who's the first in the
stream uh kohinoor banerjee
followed by min khan and gideon mj
with a retracted message for for some
reason
uh but hello everyone and hello jan
thank you for joining me
it's been a while since we've had you on
the channel
yeah been uh been been busy i hear
with hiking and stuff uh not just that
but also
covet kind of got in the way to that i
guess
we are not to mention that word that is
that is off limits
oh sorry so obviously i don't know the
new rules of the chat yeah
no no hiking okay okay
yeah yeah uh but glad to be here back
yeah
yeah i'm gonna have a nice one today so
as usual we guys are gonna enjoy some
uh not beers and uh you guys will brawl
it out and
jan is the the director of the
tournament yes uh
who's the skinhead and uh
that is that is jan almighty he's a
frequent uh
guest on the channel and um uh you will
be directing the tournament as usual so
uh have a pick uh currently i see paul
morphy
is leading the the tournament well
that's
always yes and you can use the the new
tab when choosing the game so we don't
mess up our okay or you can just use the
middle click
oh the middle click yeah but you have to
do it on the board
yeah yeah there it is oh yeah oh the
tournament director who doesn't really
know how to do it
but yeah it'll come to you yeah oh look
at this
paul morphy versus tactician magician
okay uh i'm expecting much from this
game
okay so um so
just as i am the new guy here uh so
first we have this
tournament that's uh for an hour i guess
yeah the meadow arena
okay and then after that we have another
tournament which you call the main
tournament let me just
fix that oh yes of course
oh there we go oh i got motorino is here
welcome man and
so many mods last uh
last couple of times uh yeah i didn't
have
i actually had some hair but
unfortunately i lost it
so now i'm the bald guy yeah i think you
you will now be referred to
as the bald guy yeah uh but yeah
uh what do we have here uh white is
doing well i would say
but we'll see the pawn situation seems
to be equal
yeah he didn't want to grab that because
of bishop c4 obviously
oh uh but uh
it's gonna be it's gonna be pretty wild
oh
it's a nice passed pawn on the d file
um i actually have to
be pay closer attention because i
haven't been in chess
that much as as i did before when was
the when was the last time you played
the game
uh actual game like on the internet you
think or just
classical any game any game oh yeah any
game today
okay it's been a while since you've been
in chess
but like in classical chess ah
i mean i guess now people are saying
more and more that it's
uh kind of out of fashion but uh
there are being more and more these
types of tournaments rapid blitz
over the internet yeah yeah
it'll be a while since we uh we will
enjoy uh a big classic super tournament
i think uh i think the first one like
the bigger one will be the candidates
tournament but we'll
we'll see what happens uh do we do you
know i mean
if it's okay to talk about it like do
you know uh what is the current
situation with that
with what with the candidates uh is
there like any new information
yeah they said that it should be it
should resume in september october
uh and the world church championship
will be switched over to 2021
uh but then i heard that it's not
actually going to be
uh this year okay so it it could be go
either way i guess
martin
so on the board we have a situation
where
white blundered a pawn yeah a very
important pass pawn
yeah and now i don't know it'll be a
race
i like both white and black that's
always good to say
yeah um
but here now black will be a pawn up
yeah
but okay not for long not for long g3 is
coming
maybe oh this would be this would be
e5 would be excellent now
yeah okay so this is actually very
intense paul morphy versus tactician
magician and i think we're gonna have a
flag off i don't think we'll see a win
here
yeah that is true okay and these
tournaments oh they're three plus oh
yeah three plus oh oh f3
he is going for the attack interesting
uh yeah i put the links in the
description below if you guys want to
join in
oh i haven't put a link to the meadow
arena okay i will i will add it i
thought you guys
uh friday arena here
and we're just gonna add the meadow
arena if anyone else wants to join
there we go and let me just check if
this is the correct link
5f no it's not
that's the previous one there it is now
i've
i've updated uh the links
in the description and here we have
something amazing just happened
will morphy try and flag tactician
magician
because morphe is without a loss so far
in the tournament
uh just a quick question do you need to
actually update something
or no no it's instant update oh very
nice
i have never seen that oh rook is
falling
no he can can he flag him
so if white wins this
i i would be very surprised it is
interesting
yeah another check picks up the rug 25
oh maybe a4
anything anything other than wasting
time
yeah anything other than using time
works here
just give a lot of checks yeah i think i
think he's gonna go for uh a lot of
checks
and white refuses to pre-move oh he
pre-moves now okay oh it's actually very
intense
oh now he's gonna blunder the rook don't
touch the light squares don't touch the
light squares
queen b7 quincy eight no he wants
another queen he wants it
oh look at this check he sacrificed it
too early because now he has plenty of
time
oh man oh that was that was intense that
was intense
first loss for paul morphy okay let's
see
but in the meantime country road life
yeah
we can we can check out his game
although uh we usually check out games
that are
just starting okay and we check out a
few games from the top 10 and then we go
to some other
uh spots we don't just check out the top
ten makes sense that would be that would
be crazy
yeah insane that would be insane
uh yeah who who enjoyed the video today
uh
who who is uh who is becoming a big fan
of mr barnes
[Music]
oh a checkmate yes
okay so now yeah that's unfortunate
yeah queen c3 was a bit too optimistic
he should have saved that for later
but he can always trade with bishop f6
so it's not
yeah white's uh king's side is kind of
trashed so
no not jordan john barnes
is it uh thomas wilson barnes
what are you gonna do with the rook on
a1 look at this
that's uh interesting oh that's a nice
rook
okay it seems like
country road life is in a pretty good
position
move out the queen 95 seems to be
looking good
yeah he was barnes was aggressive in
everything
i i see i should have prepared a bit
more before
because i don't know what are you
talking about i know i
saw like he played against morphy but
there's obviously some
legend to this guy oh yeah he's he's an
absolute legend
okay because uh he he's uh the only
person
ever to not just beat paul morphy by
playing f6 on the second move
okay he also has the best score against
paul morphy
uh by by losing by a large margin but
but a lesser one than anyone else
and also he has this epic mustache like
really epic
okay uh do you know
what it looks like uh yeah i've seen it
yeah yeah
like i guess today or early in the
morning
oh that's a nice one that's a nice one
very nice very nice
life okay let's see can we actually see
somehow the
games that are actually starting right
now because i know on the right there's
usually something
no you have to hover over one and then
after hovering over it
then you will be able to like enter it
like that
oh let me just check like the hand
sanitizer like that's uh
yeah i remember him i remember him from
previous tournaments but the dead games
already
pretty much ended whisper
hey whisper how you doing man
here we have hard time hearing mumbles
though
i have no idea what you mean
okay okay this is like almost beginning
almost beginning yeah yeah uh the thing
is that
most of the game are at some at a
certain stage so
this seemed like a good one to check out
oh yeah i either take the one that's
just starting out or the one where
there's like
complete madness on the board but it
seems like that this could be
soon over or not let's see
not just queen captures and then you've
just given up a rook
no no it's an exchange yeah
but white is no it's not a an exchange
white is up two pieces yeah i mean in
the end yeah
that's uh that's pretty crazy
junkie junkie usha is it
is it the junk yosha or junkie usha
or jungkyosha could be could be anything
yeah how to improve visualization in
chess
how how would you improve visualization
in chess
um i'd say i'd say play blindfold
a bit of a intro an interesting approach
there oh g4
nice yeah ken invites it yeah
ah that's unfortunate for black
oh and the rook falls on f7
hey bonjours thank you for the
contribution man uh
yeah you don't have to play chess to
enjoy it i mean that's so weird when
people say that
they say like uh is it weird that i
enjoy
watching chess but i don't play it it's
like saying is it weird that i'm
watching a
premier league in football but i'm not
actually playing i mean or
yeah or formula one i mean
and even if you expand it a bit like you
enjoy watching movies but you don't have
to be an actor
is that a good example yeah okay
especially some movies
yeah yeah yeah chess is a it's a game
for everybody so
i mean don't have to play it to enjoy it
why have i
stopped increasing your vast knowledge
uh have you seen today's video
i mean uh
if that's not vast knowledge is that my
brother no
he is my brother by chess and by beer
but
not not by blood chess brother yeah yeah
alban thanks for the contribution man so
maybe i should
uh formally introduce myself because
yeah might not be a better idea
uh since i don't want to be the bold guy
i was
i'm actually uh an occasional passerby
on this channel
from time to time i kind of joined some
streams that
agama tour has uh my name is
yan i also call myself jan almighty
i play chess from time to time because
you're humble
yeah exactly
you kind of give it away with your
username and yeah
and try to impress uh people with my
chest knowledge but
i it doesn't go very well so yeah
that's just me yeah i think that pretty
much covers it
um uh but yeah it's been a while since
you've been here and uh there are a lot
of new people
no no not yani pong nishi that that's a
different john no that's my brother
yeah no do you see a bun
on young i don't think so yeah that was
actually 10 years ago where i had that
but i had to cut off my hair because it
was just a mess
having it yeah but that was a good one
frank true slow thank you for the for
the continuous beers we will
we will enjoy them thank you cheers yeah
nepo took all the hair
[Music]
yeah someone says are they smurfing
are you again chose paul morphy uh
because the game was just beginning and
uh we had
clash on the top with uh
which arena should you play in you
should play in both
what what is jan's feeder rating oh it's
uh
this is so many so many points over nine
thousand
yeah over nine thousand and i'm
apparently a very
strong player by apparently by mad kid
four
yeah i guess i am i don't know me though
meadow is a greedy one uh we've been for
a walk before the stream but he's like
he's like insatiable when it comes to
walks
in the game we have a very uh
big advantage on white's queen side with
three
past pawns oh those are those are some
those are very fast
past pawns but be careful not to lose
your queen
you don't need the queen with so many
pawns just push them
yeah like like queen c7 brilliant
apparently you don't need a knight as
well yeah this bishop will
just take it yeah with those pawns you
don't need anything
just push a6 c5 just
they're all coming it's looking good for
white yeah
you you could play this blindfold i i
would say
what now as you said just push
there it goes there it goes
okay i misread your name in the previous
video oh could be could be
i i mean i do try to pronounce names
properly but
uh you know some some are just extreme
can i show you a photo of jan with hair
before
uh in next stream i could uh but i could
also show it to you in this stream
[Laughter]
like uh but um
what do you mean like uh with long hair
or
or with hair no with longest possible
hair
okay i actually have a good one yeah do
you have one
you know you have one oh that one but
that's a pretty critical one no no i
thought the one one that's like
a reasonable one decent yeah
[Laughter]
yeah uh i actually although on that one
you you don't have longer hair i meant
long like
long this long i have one i actually had
one but i think i've deleted it at some
point
where i actually play chess somebody
took a photo oh yeah i know that photo i
know that photo enrique
that was like 2008 or not but wouldn't
there be like a photo on google of that
perhaps yeah
if you go on google my name and chess
yeah it could be
oh there it is there's a good one oh
that's oh that's the one you mean huh
yeah on the left
oh but there's a wait there's more maybe
this one also
that that's horrible oh no no this is
the one this is the one with the longest
one
yeah and there's a chess board all right
uh there's like a 15 second delay
all right so i'm just going to show it
to you guys like this or
better yet better yet i'm just gonna
yeah i know how to do it we're gonna do
it like this
there we go just try not to embarrass me
too much no no
it's a it's a great photo i wish i had a
photo that that good
yeah no seriously
oh sorry okay tournament director
obsessed with the photo tournament
director
not directing the tournament all right
sending this to myself it seems that uh
mr
i am moser jack i don't know
is without a loss so good for him yeah
but
we can go some some other places you uh
we will return to the top 10 like in
uh like if you see a username you like
you can choose
yeah that's what i'm going for like
middle middle is always a favorite
yeah where is metal okay here oh and
it's just beginning
very nice nice that's a good time okay
so let me just
load up this photo this legendary photo
of jan
okay i think uh we have it here
uh for some reason it's not yeah it's
here
there we go there we go okay i'm gonna
comment on this uh
crazy sicilian in the meantime yeah
definitely
okay so i'm not sure which line is this
but
uh double c pawns this early and the
sicilian
doesn't look too good but okay um
both have bishop pairs i would assume
bishop e2 and small castle for white
boats okay
black is going to have a problem
developing the black square
the the light square bishop
on the other hand oh there we go there
we go
all right we're just gonna put it here
uh
for a little while you can be next to
tal here oh nice
there we go such good company yeah but
okay if people want to see it like
a little bit bigger we're just gonna
make it a little bit bigger here there
you go that's the on with long hair
did you take care of it every day yeah
how many strokes per day
oh i don't know i actually had a very
good hair dryer
use conditioner whenever i washed it and
uh
yeah but it uh one good thing about it
it was like this
curly like naturally curly hair
so it looks nice you know there we go
but it became an annoyance after a while
so
i needed to cut it off because during
summer time was just crazy
you know it was too hot to have it yeah
it's like and now
it's like when you stop smoking you have
all this free time what do you do with
your extra hair time
exactly don't lose one hour for washing
your hair
yeah but isn't it better in the summer
like you just wash it and it just dries
off
no the problem is the the other time
when you actually need to walk around
with it you know
oh and okay just uh like additional
uh heating system on your head and it's
just
yeah it becomes uh sweaty and it's uh
kind of you know probably annoying for
your
for your ex-girlfriends to have like
prettier hair than them
yeah yeah i guess that would be a
problem that was always a problem
luca solaria thank you for the
contribution man
nothing more sobering than watching
agonator after a night out oh i
i i can imagine
i'm very happy to hear that tarun says
young giving
wise advice on hairstyle yeah
i've never tried like the longest hair i
had was uh
well maybe maybe half of this yeah
like maybe half i remember some photos
of you
uh with a bit of a longer hair but i
don't think we actually hanged
when you had like longer hair yeah okay
uh i have i have another i have one here
i think
but like of yourself yeah i maybe have
it i don't know
but it's like a really old upload so i'm
gonna try and uh
try and find it it seems this
uh stream is uh getting a theme yeah
uh okay people who had long hair and
no longer have it yeah but also play
chess
oh yeah that goes without saying okay uh
why just blunder the queen so we're
gonna move on
uh meadow yeah unfortunately
okay nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
so tactician magician had a very nice
streak but unfortunately lost
let's try to find uh another interesting
username
meadow means fear oh brazil yeah we know
we know but that game is
pretty much finished yeah and meadow is
winning so
good for him uh jab jab hook
so we have a boxer in here yeah i had it
somewhere i don't anymore
yeah maybe next time i'll prepare it for
the next stream don't worry
oh definitely want to watch a game
by a bad chess player
there's even a guy called chess hater
and he won the last tournament yeah
i got mater best you are you are down to
14 seconds you you must win in the next
14 seconds
uh is han you sent me a story where
where did you send me this story
i i wonder oh checkmate wow
with nine seconds truly truly the best
let's check out the leading part
okay nasty discoveries that's a good
username
that's a good handle yeah
let's check it out it's pretty much on
the beginning yeah
we'll see play zelda with jan
yeah i just told him before the stream
like i have no idea like he was
explaining how he
achieved a good result yeah or whatever
no i managed to finish it in one sitting
and uh that's uh i mean
that is a success yeah like it's it's so
so frustrating like everything kills you
there's so many
things on the screen it's like i mean
wait uh legend of zelda for which
console was the game made
initially uh it was initially made for a
console
in japan but in europe it was shifted to
the
old nintendo nes oh and nintendo yes
okay
i i don't know the exact name of the of
the because in japan
when it came out it came out on on two
discs it wasn't like uh
one won this like on nes okay
the only thing i played was nintendo 64
when i was younger
oh that was that was a console
when i got older
yeah okay so the current situation
bishop pairs on both sides it's gonna
make the end game a bit
interesting yeah what'd you play on
nintendo 64.
i played the golden eye golden eye of
course
like so many hours spent on golden eye
um i played mario kart and just
generally super mario where you go into
castle and
you know you jump into pictures and then
you need to pass the level collect the
six stars uh i think those are the three
that i played
yeah yeah yeah i i'm pretty sure
everyone
had those three and no one was even
interested in the other ones
a bunch of kazooie banjo-kazooie yeah
yeah
i haven't uh haven't uh played that one
but i i know
no of it yeah that's also a very good
one
and the last one was just some i don't
exactly remember the name but it's uh
i don't know some car racing game
i mean it was okay but uh most of the
time i was spending
playing actually a bunch of kazooie and
goldeneye
yeah well then i was such a such a
such a game
adi bansal those are those are some
wicked wicked emotes
okay oh very strong pawn center we have
by black
yeah just in case we haven't mentioned
if you want to join the main
arena the link is in the description
below it says agamato friday arena
so everyone is welcome uh
i think uh this is uh the one tournament
where we haven't uh
where we haven't put any requirements so
even if you haven't played a single game
unleashes you can still play
oh but you usually did that to
discourage cheaters right
yeah but this time i didn't do it
because everyone thinks
i always do it so i just want to see
what happens
it's a test yeah it's a trap
uh oh interesting situation here now
oh very nice use of the bishop
the rook is spent oh both players with
with nice bishops but
okay but now white has the advantage now
white has the bishop pair
yeah and also if that bishop is picked
up that just rookie one
oh he oh no he had it
very nice checkmate that's the
discoveries
kind of missed that nice nasty discovery
yeah but it was a
it was a free rook wasn't it yeah i mean
it wasn't yeah yeah it was really bishop
can capture it yeah yeah
and the story let's see
people still asking her what is daughter
the engine boy doing
uh well he still has a young baby
and he's all right you know strolling it
around town
uh you know the the good stuff prince
agatha
i'm from croatia oh interesting
let's support uh against countrymen
coder ankur
let's see what happens adi bansai thanks
man
unless you're referring to yan which is
also cool
what's happening okay
is yelena playing uh she could be
i don't know she's not here so i don't
know
but no she's not online oh
i don't know but i think i think abby is
playing
yeah i'll be explaining we're gonna
check out the game by abi maybe after
this one we can check out hobbies game
okay i just have to point myself this is
his username
yeah okay i'm gonna search for it
all right so let's see what what
happened wha what's happening here i
like black i definitely like black
b4 now wins on the spot but he prepares
it first yes
before now yes whoa
now it's uh capture scout now it's just
whatever
oh that hurt that hurt oh
resigned yeah he knows he knows what's
coming
do we have okay we have a search here
what what's the internet
maybe it would be nad yeah that's him
just hover over it uh and uh he's
not playing at the moment ah so but
we'll give it a few seconds
you have to like hover on hover hover
and hover
okay one more hover one more hover
nope uh okay maybe one more
yeah okay we skipped okay let's see
what is the situation okay uh
a bit of an unkind username at first
place yeah uh we haven't checked out the
game from chess
oh that's just hater one oh hater one
yeah just hitter one that's not actually
just hater the guy who won the
or maybe it is yeah i'm pretty sure it
is but i i think he's a smurf and he
just uh you know wasted his previous
account and now he maybe made another
one
okay because he's very like he's 1387
and he's destroying everyone so i
imagine that's him
okay let's see
yeah i i'm pretty sure like uh half the
people here are smurfs i mean
you're not tricking anyone guys what's a
smurf
smurf oh someone like who's for what
2000 and then he creates another account
to
be beat all of those below 1700 to you
know feel
good about himself oh okay and also to
enjoy himself
i didn't know there's an like uh actual
term
for people like that yeah i don't know
why it's called a smurf i'm pretty sure
there's like a good reason for it
but yeah that's that's what they're
called uh in
every game okay
oh like generally okay across the cake
i received what cake oh the cake yeah
but for smurfs is i i guess it's really
difficult to figure out who is and who
isn't you know
smurfing yeah but i mean if you're like
1300 and you have like 10 victories in a
row against everyone
i i would call that like either a smurf
or uh
or very good prodigy yeah
or uh extensively learning during the
week
and preparing for their ah sean o'hara
says smurfs
smurfs are small but more powerful than
they appear
yeah okay maybe i don't know if it's
that but
it sure sounds sounds good if i remember
the current
cartoon correctly wasn't it something
like that they
joined hands in order to
uh i i don't know sing no
no join hands in terms of like battling
it out with gargamel
to you know keep together like i
remember that i remember that
cartoon but i don't like remember the
like a single
episode you know in itself i remember
gargamel and
azrael his cat and the smurfs but and
the the stromfera like the the female
smurf
and like there's only one of her i mean
what's up what's up with that
i mean the the person raises questions
yeah person who created that is is a bit
weird
okay very nice or maybe there maybe
there's like a good reason
for they're only being one one
female smurf but that's just
uh how it is you know like with the bees
you have one queen you know yeah but she
wasn't the queen
yeah there was that papa smurf yeah
oh since we are with uh like on this
topic of
cartoons i bet it's soon to be over
gulliver's blunders someone said it was
about some gamers back in the 90s that
were banned from a tournament and they
had a nickname smurf
uh so could be could be anything
female smurf was created by gargamel
really
like white uh sounds fishy but no it's
actually smart
to you know create commotion between the
smurfs
otherwise they'd be too powerful yeah
oh the girl was some experiment from
gargamel to trick the smurfs really i
i mean i have no idea i like that
there are a lot of people like i know
like about this trivia
yeah like actually general knowledge
yeah
like do you don't know about the smurfs
yeah i guess
yeah she was supposed to create chaos
among among male smurfs yeah that
makes sense interesting oh there's
another is this character
that's that's a common one when i'm on
the street yeah
okay we're just gonna time out this user
no copy pasting guys oh do you have like
uh moderators yeah yeah yeah we do
okay nice so that's something that is
new for example
it didn't have moderators last time when
i was on the stream
so it must have been a while really yeah
i'm pretty sure like
like i had one no no no and you said
like next time there will be moderators
oh
when was that at the
500k stream did we have one for 600
no okay 10 on 500. yeah when was that
i don't know i guess you you know when
you reached 500 nope
me neither nope i i forget stuff yeah
do i have a girl do i have girlfriends
yes like 11.
i'm not like a smurf yeah
uh once murpheta cannot hold this guy
donnydarko explains the smurfs at best
i i'm actually a big fan of donnie darko
but i don't remember
him talking about the smurfs or she
in that movie wasn't there a rabbit
in the movie yeah the demonic rabbit but
i really can't remember any talk of the
smurfs i really have to rewatch that
that movie yeah
no zelda today no we're keeping youtube
zelda clean
yeah zelda zelda only only uh on twitch
do we have some premium zelda action
okay oh colored tal yeah we could
uh i'm kind of switching it up between
colored and the black and white style
someone sent me a uh you see this uh
image of
misha someone sent me a colorized
version of misha but it was colorized by
by deep learning technique oh and it
looks really
really good i i think i've seen it on
one of the last videos
yeah yeah yeah
all right so maximus 107
against again chess hater next game is
gonna be one
do you think that there were already 106
maximuses
uh registered i mean it is a popular
name oh
interesting interesting situation yeah
what do you do here
rookie one and you win not necessarily
but
it is something to think about this is a
better move
definitely uh but we are
very close to the end of the tournament
i didn't even notice
yeah yeah uh because this one's a short
one it's like 55 minutes
it's not one hour it's 55 minutes so we
have time enough for one game
before we switch to the main arena and
maybe to
get fresh beverages yeah definitely
i also thought about making the main
arena only an hour not an hour and a
half
uh to maybe maybe accept some challenges
but i thought now let's
let's keep it the same and if we we'll
see how it goes maybe we
yeah maybe we can play some hand in
brain also have you ever played that
what have you ever played hand in brain
no what's that
i like uh we play against someone
you say knight i have to play move with
the knight but i don't know which knight
ah and you say queen and if you say king
maybe you mean castle but you can't say
castle like maybe
you know oh nice yeah it's uh it's
pretty wild
sounds interesting but okay but we
probably need to do it with
more time because we could no no it's
actually
you you can choose any time but then if
if you play like a three minute then if
we go below 30 seconds then only the
hand plays
oh okay and if you play like a five
minute
uh then if you get below a minute i
think then
there are like some unwritten rules
about this
okay but we set up the rules right it
isn't yeah
of course yeah we can set up the rules
yeah definitely okay
sounds sounds pretty good opinion on the
english opening
oh it's it's the best one oh we have a
very interesting situation
uh the the guy who doesn't think too
much of himself
but he paused the tournament he he he
thinks he's going to win what about
country road life what if he wins the
game i think that it's more about that
he cannot squeeze in the game
why i'm not sure but let's see country
road life just finished so no game for
him
no but he he did press pause which is
weird oh but now now
he has to berserk if he doesn't berserk
and win
uh he will not have enough time oh
viserion is here
i'm just gonna uh open up a game because
it's
uh pretty much yeah yeah
sure and this one is oh this one is also
from the top
can i cover the rest of the alpha zero
games you mean the
the other 90 we haven't covered
what yeah they released a hundred games
and i think we covered
ten of the nicest ones well the nicest
ones i thought were the nicest ones
okay milo rules says is your friend on
instagram
jan are you on instagram uh i don't know
if i've told you this but i actually
deleted it like a month ago
oh really yeah yeah i decided to be
as much as possible of social social
media because
i figured it just uh it kind of is a
waste of time
yeah so unless you need it like for
business
it's uh it's a waste of time yeah indeed
so the tournament is finished if you
would
like to uh about the winners no i'm just
gonna
bring us some refreshments you can uh
you can call out the winners
okay so with this meadow arena
today uh the winner is i just suck
which is very interesting uh with a very
nice berserk rate i must
might add second place hand sanitizers
people like to berserk in this
tournament 94
looks pretty good and in third place
country road life so these are the guys
who have been mainly
on uh in the top 10 so
congratulations to all of you and
yeah i guess we could take up on some
challenges right do you want to play a
hand and brain immediately no
you can accept the one because i think
you only have time for like one game
uh okay so maybe uh before yeah maybe
after maybe after the second tournament
we'll see how it goes okay can i just
play it here do you want to maybe
we'll keep it uh for publishing later
okay
uh but you can just accept one here yeah
with uh
like right click and uh
well let's see let's see let's see how
how much do i want to play
oh we have an s quest here this is going
to be interesting okay
uh right click you said yeah
oh no they they made it not a button
yeah
yeah so just open like a separate tab
and
that'll do where is it
there we go there we go that's hand and
brain
no that was hand in hand actually
okay let me find evanesce i want to play
against him i haven't played against him
in a while
unless he decided to leave
uh okay no i don't choose that one even
yeah okay just that one it's a casual
game
casual again it had a pretty good score
there
oh yeah we played we played some games
wait you don't have that part where you
click
and then there's a thing there's a what
like you click and then you click on the
square
oh but usually it's purple it
kind of tells you where the piece can go
seriously
yeah yeah i don't know i don't know if
it's a setting or something
like but you you're in the wrong place
if you don't know
where it goes uh of course but
uh i mean i've never seen that
yeah it's definitely a thing on leeches
thanks for the beer so maybe
it's an odd beer actually okay sorry uh
yeah yeah i've never seen that i've
never seen that
okay so this is the part where you try
to annoy me to lose right
yeah something like that
all right what do we have here a free
pawn
i've seen the d6 spawn gambited more
than a few times
let's let's try to
oh that's very that's very sneaky oh
interesting ready to
oh you are you are really going after
that b6 square
yeah it's very important right here hey
merano uh
sorry i haven't seen the question uh
we've been uh
enjoying this wild game
not bare yeah it's not bitter not bitter
like you have to say it quickly oh
interesting interesting
how i chose the name agar matar well
there were some names to choose from and
this one seemed the the most appropriate
check seeing a ukrainian i'm not
ukrainian dude
how tall is jan i have no idea
i'm pretty pretty tall actually no
it's 177 i like to say
so that's in feet i have no idea how
much
so let's play this and and you don't
care
tournament link please oh the tournament
link is in the description below
so everyone who wants to join the big
tournament uh just click on the link in
the description and you are
already playing
why is your friend so swole
do you mean swollen or swole i don't i
don't know the words swole
also is that like a good thing how to
improve from 1400 to 2000
uh just grab 600 points yeah
uh that's i mean study the end game i
think studying the end game will will do
the job done
oh means muscular ah
that's it man how how are you achieving
this
it's just like i'm thinking every
morning when i wake up
how to achieve some wholeness know that
i should be
swollen i'm just thinking so hard about
it and then
it just happens
it's uh the power of the subconscious
mind
so no lifting involved whatsoever zero
zero lifting zero don't have time for
that
no no a lot of chess actually yeah
lift lifting rooks yeah lifting rooks
right
okay this is a very interesting moment
and
running from nasty discoveries yeah
because that
once that night comes into the game i
guess it will be
this one yeah that's a good one night
could be could be pretty pretty crazy i
hope i'm not blundering anything
seems pretty good yeah
i should stream more often i i do
actually stream
on twitch quite a lot but i'm mostly
streaming zelda nowadays i'm trying to
become a master of zelda
croatian women fine right yeah
you could put it that way yeah
i guess i mean
pretty much bobby fisher versus lubo
who wins it's gonna be interesting it's
hard to say
bobby bobby against anyone is is a
pretty pretty tough bet
where is josiah i i do not know i i
think he's either working
or or or making some videos i would say
the woman next to misha is a hottie
ah hey man we are we're okay
haven't i haven't seen each other in a
while so uh we decided to have some not
beers and stream some chess
how are you doing man
a couple of days ago you you said you
were you know taking it easy
let me check when is this oh it already
started so
let's close this tab and so this is a
tournament where
anyone can come right yeah anyone anyone
okay so let's start from the top
i guess the guy who is sneaky
already win won two games so let's check
him out
who won two games the sneaky guy okay
or maybe his name is luca something
and then luca yeah ah like from
luca he is from croatia
yeah yeah i don't know any luca v
are any of the martich family playing i
don't know
could be it's still it's still early in
the tournament but uh yeah
i mean if any of you want to join since
uh that
the tournament has officially started
the link in the description says
agar matar friday arena i'm even going
to put
uh like there will be an x
in front of it so you guys know where it
is there you go
now people were think will be thinking
it is the tenth
how was my surgery you you actually
think i had heart surgery
three days ago and i'm streaming now
that's
that's that's pretty optimistic man
you're unbeatable
yeah uh i like the machine it's still
being planned it's still being planned
okay sharkboy is a new player
he has a question mark by close to his
name so yeah see
if i if i didn't allow this he couldn't
play
so we'll see what happens yeah we'll see
what happens
oh yeah i hope it goes well too oh
sorry omega gamer yeah that's a good
question
actually the the next episode of uh mata
best moments is uh coming out
right after this stream like like maybe
even during the stream
as soon as i click publish
my uh my english skills were just
questioned
why since i said i said luca means
sneaky
wrote it means cunning yeah it does mean
cunning yeah i'm sorry for that
uh luca luca you would actually say
oniony
you know yeah yeah oniony yeah
uh can't wait for hikaru to react to the
new video oh yeah me too
i can't wait to watch it actually but uh
wait
wait until i make a reaction on hikaru's
reaction to my video
that's gonna be you know some edgar
allan poe stuff
what's up with my heart uh well nothing
wrong with the heart but
the heart valve is not really doing its
job
so we're going to have to you know do
something about that
yeah reaction infinite loop activated
a reaction inception yeah that and
that's the stuff
oh i can't even read this reactsception
wow oh
yeah this is a good question um so
regarding your tutorial videos i noticed
you started doing those as well
well i made two so i wouldn't i would i
wouldn't say i started making them
but uh yeah i thought uh
i i only do the the ones that i myself
like
i haven't forgotten about them it's just
that uh it's been so long since i've
actually
looked at it okay like i know i i would
be able to like
deliver mate with a bishop at night but
i don't know like the exact terminology
to explain it to someone
okay and now i do oh really you know
actually how to do it
because yeah i think i don't know yeah
but it's like uh
i've seen uh some some famous famous
authors of chess books they
don't think that it's actually relevant
like that it happens like once or twice
in your life and you shouldn't spend
your time
on that as there is much more important
stuff for you to you know
do knight of six kind of loses
but i had it in a classical game uh
against the bellani
oh nice
and yeah i i didn't know like the any
special theory but i knew like the
general stuff and i was able to do it
okay nice i don't think i ever had it in
the game
yeah it is real uh say that to ana
yeah well but okay to be fair anna had
like a few seconds on the clock i
believe
oh nasty works nicely done shark boy
nicely done look at how much rating he
got
pretty good yeah mr any sorry sorry
about that man
oh hand sanitizer played in the last
tournament
yeah he's playing in both of them oh
yurcha is playing oh really
yeah oh nice i don't know if that's him
but it could be
could be him is he saying his croatian
no
doesn't like to brag i i will ask him
okay i will ask him oh this is playing i
think
i don't know if we played only chess i
don't know who
me and yorcha before uh i know i haven't
so apparently i mean apparently i guess
everybody knows about it but me you have
an emoji
of yourself oh it's not an emoji of
myself
it i mean it is but it's not uh it's
like um
like a logo made emoji okay uh adam made
that oh yeah
your head queen f2 and he is up a bishop
so good job there against the abhinav
anand yeah but he has to be careful with
uh this pawn going too close
to his king yeah the uh rishaba yeah
that's the emoji yeah that's the one
it's i actually like it it's it's it's a
nice one
oh it's the one from uh also there's
metal
nice pretty cool
[Music]
yeah it's the dog all right so oh
that's a discovery and eight six and
that's it no
no oh actually no it's not it
but it's uh need to tread lightly
yeah but what yeah no oh no no queen c6
and then you you can start playing
let's see rook f3
yeah that's nothing because he will
never be able to capture
yeah philip disarro thanks for the
contribution man
i am an excellent youtuber why thank you
thank you for that
okay oh nice going after mate
rook h5 yeah you're just playing pretty
good
okay what is that yeah that one has to
capture
capture
and now mate okay no rook h3 yeah yeah
oh right right nice and meat
wow yeah it's nicely done nicely done
i don't see these tactics oh that's
worrying
meadow doing the dance of the engines in
the background yeah
yeah yeah it is yurcha yeah he he says
that's him
very nice all right nicely done four
wins in a row
congratulate him in my name a pretty
impressive win
yeah oh bruno
oh i cannot be a stream where i'm at
if i don't show a game from bruno yeah
look at bruno's bullet oh my god bruno
is i i think
he's been a very busy bee he should
[Music]
plays a lot of bullet yeah
please do something people are using
chess engines
all right let me use my mental capacity
to
to reach them somehow
there we go is it working i i think i
think we did it yeah
good job i think we did it there you go
yeah
other than that i i don't think i have
any any other options
okay what about a check on g4
knight g4 evanesco says i lost two games
because i didn't
play anything i was busy so
so so what man what oh
unesco is a moderator right yeah yeah
i hope you're not as lazy moderating as
you are playing ivanesco
[Laughter]
bruno has a nice set of pieces but
is down material yeah
but look at this triple triple g pawn
no i think i think white white takes
this easily
yeah with the yeah i mean the bishop
pair just laughs at
the queen's face oh oh
he had to do it yeah he had to do it
it's a crazy bishop pair against
yeah but bruno yeah just f6 that's it oh
he blocks the bishop nice okay bishop he
has to go bishop do you want the
three blocks the queen yeah seven now a7
game
nice bruno legend there you're legendary
bruno
very good oh but the pawns are still
coming what
what no bruno up on time too much
very nice free dog thanks for the
contribution man
let's see the situation btn chess
which is my favorite youtube chess
channel other than agad matar
i i have no idea nakamura
uh yeah maybe because maybe
he he does he does do reviews of my best
moment so it could be but
uh but no so
the challenge i actually don't know yeah
people ask me this but i actually do not
watch any other
chess chess youtubers as
sometimes sometimes when i'm like having
a beer somewhere and
if i were like subscribed to some other
channels and some super
awesome game happens in the world and
someone covers it and i see like oh they
already covered that game
then i'm like oh maybe i shouldn't be
enjoying this beer maybe i should go
home make a video
uh this way you know okay i'm not
bothered by anything
i guess what you mean ah interstellar
knows you there you go
oh yeah yeah hello hello
interstellar nomad uh but there are so
many to choose from
uh like uh i know i know chess network
is not all that busy nowadays
uh he isn't twitch he's not i believe
that busy on youtube there's uh
yozaro is doing a very nice quality
content there's hanging pawns
also from croatia very nice content for
for beginners
uh what what others are there i mean
if you're interested in learning theory
like st louis chess channel really has a
lot of
extensive videos on openings there's uh
uh i would say that there isn't a bad
one you can watch like
i would say they are all good
i don't yeah eric rosen as well
okay i remember him
i actually only know i actually only
know levi from twitch
uh so i haven't seen any of his stuff on
youtube
uh but i i imagine he's on both
yeah mate and king crusher those are uh
mata is the pioneer of youtube chess of
course he's the he's the greatest legend
[Music]
here is mata yeah hi
this is mato this is mata yeah
so good yeah that's like a that's like
total chess asmr
hmm
interesting interesting oh yeah john
bartholomew of course
i mean uh but but he's mostly a streamer
i don't uh i don't think he's like
making uh
videos per se uh i'm pretty sure he
mostly streams and he's too busy now
with uh
with the the work he does uncheckable
um it seems that deutsche kind of
improved in his uh
time game because his yeah he was
terrible on time yeah
yeah it's quite good actually playing
against the player
with so much higher rating and uh
attacking all the time i'm
really impressed yeah by his improvement
here yeah
uh oh two are twitch affiliates uh
allowed to stream on on youtube well i
mostly stream zelda
on twitch so i don't think they they
care if i stream chess
a little bit and i did apply for partner
like yesterday
uh so i'm very happy that we only did
two chess streams but i applied for
partnership on twitch before the second
uh chest stream so basically we we
achieved partner on twitch by by
just playing zelda okay interesting
okay i mean they still have to accept my
application but
i think i think we we were able to do it
and now check and pick up the rook oh no
there's no check sorry
yeah sorry but okay it's no it's still
it's still completely winning
yeah but it's a bit difficult no it's
not
the whole oh oh man unfortunately yeah
okay tough luck but
davor drew chile you just made mr barnes
t-shirt design
well if you if you send it to me via
email we can show it to everyone on
stream
i would be i would be very happy to see
that
hey leslie yeah we will have uh some
some uh premium zelda action tomorrow
morning
um will i ever stream on almighty chess
again
well you know how they say never say
never yeah
maybe like a stream from the highest
mountain in the world
yeah that's gonna be is there internet
there
they have to join by satellite i
actually read a book by this guy who
actually
went to the south pole and obviously he
needed to use just
uh satellite stuff to be in
communication with other people okay so
i would guess no but yeah this could be
like an interesting
thing to put on youtube at some point
okay but now with with musk's starling
satellites
um like you will be able to have
internet anywhere
well okay that's like the point of them
so i guess
you know it doesn't matter how far you
climb you will be online
yeah so because everyone obviously needs
that
yeah i mean
but you don't you have to like take a
photo of yourself and then send it to
the you know climbers society
for them to approve your uh yes but i do
fine
yes but i do that after i come home you
know oh that's weird i i thought
that you have to do it you know with a
geo location while you're actually there
no so it's not edited well i i'm
assuming that people who actually do it
don't really go that far you know
um it is the most important thing is
that you
take a picture with a significant part
of that
control point yeah yeah which is regular
you can fake everything
yeah yeah and that's it you know
mohan thank you very much that is uh
that is a bit far-fetched but i like
your optimism
you are a legend and will end up in
chess commentators mount rushmore
does such a thing exist already no okay
although yeah we should call it
differently like mount rook more
or something like that yeah
i'm sure there are are better better
things to call it it's just
the first one i i got
decided uh on a game by i am trash
because i'm really fascinated by these
usernames that
people are using a german youtuber
thought there's
internet on mars i'm pretty sure there
is i mean
the the mars rovers are communicating
with earth uh somehow
might not be via internet but they do
have some sort of communication
what are we drinking uh well jan is
having a not beer
and i'm i'm having like uh some sort of
a
super light white wine
[Music]
yes do i watch any comedians only samai
only sami sami playing chess is the
is the best comedy
because he's bad or no he's funny okay i
don't know who that is
ah he's a he is an indian comedian
uh gone chess player youtuber okay uh
the the guy who you were telling me
about game changer
total game changer
let's see here all right i'm just gonna
check if uh
if there's elite sent me yeah he he
actually did he sent it to me ha ha
okay this is very interesting to see uh
a design for a mr barnes t-shirt all
right
oh i like it
oh that mr barnes all right we're gonna
we're gonna show it to people we can
actually
maybe we can squeeze him in between you
and and misha
oh i'm thinking i'm thinking maybe we
could do it
okay let's uh let's try and do it okay
okay
and then you guys decide if uh if we're
doing the
if we're doing the mr barnes
maybe they're going to vote me out since
uh this guy's pretty popular
no i don't think so i don't think so
all right so we're gonna move on a
little bit to the left
yawn you don't need so much space like
you have too much hair there we go
look at this thin figure yeah yeah we
can squeeze you in all the way here
let's put a little bit to the left there
we go okay
and now we added the mr barnes
image all right mr barnes
um where is he
oh that's that's a bit that's a large
image wow
that's a big one there we go that's
you need good quality for yeah there we
go
oh that mr barnes what do you think guys
do we do this as a t-shirt
like i mean who who wouldn't enjoy this
sorry about blocking the game but it's
only going to be for like
a second black is winning there we go
just so you know
oh i think we actually can fit mr barnes
right next to you here
there we go all right so it's ian mr
barnes and
misha quite a team there we go
hope no one with ocd is watching yeah
i'm kind of on the edge already
all right there we go okay
all right mr barnes is there
ah yeah people are saying nicely
positioned there you go
i think it actually was nicely
positioned i mean i had like maybe five
seconds to do it
it was uh it was pretty crazy the game
is finished
let's see what's the situation on top
exotic camaro oh i do not know this
nickname yeah
total berserker gorham chess lab do you
know him yes
he is from zagreb i only played one game
unleashes against him i beat him in the
french defense
i remember he's very happy uh maybe not
the game but
yeah it was the french ry morrison
welcome welcome to excellent subscribers
man
welcome to the team
we have a carpool style position which
is going to open up
yeah all right i i'm i'm
i'm thinking rooks get exchanged and
then
white sacrifices the knight for
something here
but yeah once the knight hits c4 those
are oh those are
those are hard to keep that's a monster
knight
will barnes keep attacking barnes is
still attacking
like barnes is you know he's in a
constant
attacking flux ever since that game in
1858
or rather the match oh i i apologize
to those with ocd yeah i mean i i really
tried to do it
yeah oh there's the chalky oh
he also gets uh yeah emoji
nice is final fantasy my favorite after
chess
i would say so yeah but zelda is
becoming a close second favorite
yeah mr barnes still attacking to this
day
hey daniel worster welcome to excellent
subscribers man
okay white is getting momentum
and rook d5 and e5 oh
or that one yeah i would put the rook
behind the past pawn
because i i heard that's what you should
do
oh he wanted to put the other one there
okay
so i ig good versus communist
23 so there were 22 communists before
only registered yeah already
ah you use your advantage to learn chess
i i am very glad to hear that
oh just chilling yeah that's that's like
my oldest quote
yeah misha is actually gray i thought
i'd switch it up from you know
gray color gray color not not like make
it colorful
all the time
okay yeah fully in the spirit of barns
when am i going to do a quiz competition
i i hope very soon i hope very soon that
we can make it like a
like a weekly thing that's that's the
dream i actually only made this channel
to someday be able to do a chess quiz
but then you already do it in a way once
once but it was it was very hard to pull
it off because uh
when you write something and press enter
and someone else does that
to you it seems like you were the first
and to them it seems like you were the
first yeah because of the
connection and then everyone's like and
and i see differently who's the first
and i'm like okay he was first and
they're like no
so uh there is one one uh one client
that we can use
agar metrino sent it to me so i will i
will look into that one
but i am actually hoping to to start a
chess quiz
fairly soon i did make one on instagram
though
uh i think when i hit 20k followers on
instagram we did a
short chess quiz oh through stories
no no i i had like a instagram live
oh instagram live yeah i i also wanted
to try it out
it's actually pretty bad okay yeah oh
instagram live yeah you're not missing
out on much
yeah you didn't want to try it at all
mr barnes looks like a member in
motorhead
yeah they wish because of the mustache
when do i expect to reach 1 million
subscribers i i don't have any
expectations regarding that
uh i get i guess it will happen but
you know whenever it happens it's any
any day now it's a good happening yeah
row number and column letter is not
visible yes that is
that is by design who came second in the
1959 canada
tournament oh that's a good one do you
know who came second
of course who always comes second oh
right yeah yeah
oh i took a picture with charis
i mean i have it somewhere but none of
the statues actually
look like them like the statue of misha
looks nothing like misha
i mean the thing is uh the place
since i was in tallinn they had a statue
of him
when he was younger and that uh thing
that you
sent me is from another town which i
didn't go to uh okay okay
but even the one where he's younger
looks nothing like him when he was
younger
yeah so that's that's a shame i'm gonna
if you're interested i'm actually gonna
quickly try to find it in the library
from estonia
yeah have it somewhere too bad if you
had instagram you'd know where it is
yeah right so it has it has some
downsides to not having it but i think
the the perks are you know
much much greater
how do you pronounce your channel's name
there you go
quite quickly yeah
yeah like the hair does look like but
you you guys actually have similar
hairstyle
yeah this is why i also came second
everywhere yeah
but i should like brighten it up a bit
so people can see but yeah can you send
it to me so people
can see sure yan with hey david kimura
thank you for the contribution man oh
this is actually a bit
lighter one if you want yeah sure okay
even though i look uh imagine being
zero degrees in tallinn so who will win
the legendary chess tournament
well either either magnus or if uh
uh if chucky decides to play like like
he can
then he will win so i think it's either
of the two
but i will also send you a much more
important game
a much more important photo which you
will appreciate more
okay a picture with tal of course which
is uh
i mean this looks just yeah i mean it's
like they they said
yeah chucky it's like they said uh we
have this head
do you guys are you guys planning on
making any sculptures they said oh yeah
we're going to make a statue of the
magician of riga oh all right
have this head yeah it's pretty bad i
mean it says his name
here but yeah i would never say that's
him
like if i visit riga and i'm planning to
i will i will
pay a sculptor to to change that
okay okay i'm gonna uh where do you want
to want me to send it
send it to oh to agatha mata it's uh
gmail
sounds like a good place to send
pictures yeah
what about the podcast guest uh i do
have a guest for the next podcast
planned
uh tournament director are you directing
sorry
sorry guys why is carlson playing
legends well he
he is kind of a big big thing in chess
so i i guess it does make sense for him
to play
and he also qualified for it i'm kind of
sensing this is gonna be the last time
i'm gonna be invited to be a tournament
director
sca training what kind of a training is
that
uh i do not know but goran chess lab is
playing again all right
make just a culture how would you do
that it's
it already is a culture
who is the guy in blue the blue guy
yeah i mean
what show is that from the blue men's
group oh mr barnes netflix series yeah
isn't that like uh that's an actual
group
a blue man group isn't that like a
arrested development
or something like that yeah smurf
there was a thing on arrested
development yeah anand is playing
legends i mean making a tournament
called chess legends and
not inviting anand would be would be
pretty bad
but there's uh ana displaying uh kramnik
is playing gate fun displaying of the
of the older uh generation uh
of course vasily van chuk uh is this
zelda no but thank you for the
contribution and thank you josh for the
contribution
this game is a bit older than zelda some
i don't know how older but way older
oh chess yeah oh yeah it's pretty old
oh dollar no problem it's uh it's quite
the design
you put a little you know oily feel to
it which really really uh you know
puts uh puts the the uh mr barnes
mustache
in a spotlight
uh uh there you see again motorino says
it well chess was invented in 1933 by dr
charles chess
what okay
yeah um
or or even better charles chazzavier
yeah
good okay
uh black is pretty oh in a pretty good
situation we fit says the blue man group
is a percussion group that
are actually quite spectacular there you
have it
what uh percussion and they are
spectacular
and we're going to trust mr fitz yeah i
would i would put something uh by the
blue man group now for everyone to enjoy
uh but youtube doesn't like when we do
that so i'm just gonna enjoy it
after the stream okay yeah lovely work
dollar thank you davor that's uh
i mean it is very impressive cronaldinho
i i actually wanted to show a game from
oh canaldina is playing math is fun
i guess and the crown dino is playing
against him so oh it's a mass
i i thought it was a myth could be
i mean now you see uh what i'm thinking
about and what are you thinking
yeah no because you said math you didn't
say math okay so that's why i thought
yeah and now it's my fault yeah
yes i am cool there you go
an acknowledgement from the chat that's
what i wanted ah you've seen them on a
cruise
like they were playing on a cruise you
were on
a bunch of blue people sounds like uh
sounds like an awesome cruise
have i tried chess battle royale from
ubisoft no the only chess game from
ubisoft
i've tried was the chess master series
and that yes
i i recommend that to everyone that's a
good one like
grand master edition that's chess master
11 with the josh waitzkin academy
like that that's the best stuff like
josh waitskin is the absolute man
um educational yeah if we had more room
up there we would put a put a photo of
josh weights in there
whoa oh nicely done yeah math is fun
he got he got nervous because we're
showcasing his game unfortunately
unfortunately for chronology but this
was a good one this was a really good
one
youtube isn't showing when a live stream
came up yeah youtube does that
they're they're super weird
okay yeah better luck next time but okay
you expect to see us with masks next
time yeah
there is no quarantine in croatia like
yeah now
now you have to wear masks like when you
go into a shop
but like our our town is like the only
town in croatia i think uh
oh no our our province is the only one
in croatia without any cases of
infection
uh in the second wave in the second wave
yeah yeah
but i also believe in the first wave
because there weren't any official
official ones yes they were yeah i heard
there were but not officially like was
there like an official announcement
yes oh many times yeah i don't go out
that much yeah me neither but yeah uh
it was a problem in that old people song
oh i know that
yeah but they also don't go out so it's
not a problem
yeah so it was contained yeah
okay so oh very nice
very very nice thoughts on smearing
versus anand rapid game where he took
one minute and 43 seconds
oh that was uh uh
it was one of those moments where he
knew he had to spend that much to
remember what
they played in the past but then when he
finally did he played an
absolute brilliancy take a moment and
look at this
very nice situation okay not anymore but
i mean there was so many
things hanging okay obviously mate was
hanging
yeah but not quarter nail
yeah or is it corona ill
that's what i thought yeah but i read it
cornell i need to shave
why would you say that i it's been a
while since i even had
a little bit of beard like this is this
this you can't even call this a beard
this is like you know some
some light hair
yeah like maybe you know light fur
oh black is going for it is there any
newspaper only exclusive for chess
lovers
yeah we do like in croatia we have the
the chess messenger
really i mean yes and oh that's not a
newspaper
i don't think they made meant like
actual newspaper
but worldwide no i know you have like
the american chess magazine they
they were pretty active but now nothing
is happening so i i don't think they're
like making a number
an issue yeah the cushion is chilling in
the background that's
that cushion always you know enjoys
all right yeah the smiley face
oh the chessenger yeah the chest injury
but that could also be a chess
passenger oh very nice situation here
rook f2 rook a2
oh rook a2
what rook f3
rook a2 oh nice also looks good
nice now black wins there's no defense
i mean king h1 and then rook f1 picks up
the bishop
yeah will he see it
yeah he will oh he's going to take down
a 2200 that's nice
yeah unless those pawns do their job
he's gonna put a
nail in his coffin i don't think so with
30 seconds i think
because he's just gonna pre-move this
he's just gonna pre-move this
and it's gonna be pretty crazy yeah see
he's removing it
bishop d6 rook e3 that's how i would
play yeah but
black cannot afford to waste time yeah
like push the pawn
oh maybe maybe not with f5 something
something
no ah push the pawn yeah push the pawn
just push the pawn yeah he's gonna push
it again
but now this guy is coming a2
bishop d4 okay yeah bishop d4
covers both both queening squares yeah
but with seven seconds on the clock i
don't see it happening
yeah now you pick up that captures
captures
and that's it bishop h8 oh two seconds
now just just win the win the pawn win
the pawn yeah now it's at least a draw
although i will win this really yeah
okay because you can infinitely pre-move
you can just grab
three queens and then pre-moved to the
mate
okay i guess uh
peep and choke a pipanchuk yeah he's
always he's always playing
uh i think he actually got in the top
three
in in couple of tournaments after this
game i'm gonna go
a little bit behind just to see how the
rest of the tournament is going
yeah have you seen uh you've seen the uh
picky blinders right yes was it good
yeah i only saw the first episode the
one with uh
or just the beginning of the first
episode the one where where the woman
you know
blows something in the horse and then
everyone thinks like she put a spell on
him and that he's going to win
that's some you know complete witchcraft
uh you know
yeah control the betting it's a like a
gypsy thing
yeah in the series but they only do it
like there's no actual magic they only
do it so people would bet on that horse
yeah yeah because they are actual
okay i don't want to spoil it so yeah
yeah
yeah i was going to watch the good
series and i like that guy who
who who stars in it i can't remember his
name but he
uh plays in batman i think he's the guy
that darth knight yeah he's the one the
scarecrow scarecrow
yeah you know his name no yeah
no hi mans thank you for the
contribution man it escapes me
he also played in dunkirk yeah i don't
think i ever knew
actually pretty sure someone knows yeah
celia murphy yeah acilian murphy if
that's the correct pronunciation of his
name
yeah the one the woman blows something
into the horse
demonetized yeah that's how
that's how youtube rolls
[Laughter]
oh man nice why don't i try becoming an
i
am why don't you try becoming an i am
it's uh it's not that easy plus you
can't really travel
and play uh nowadays yeah
can you so the titles are still reserved
just for classical chess
right there yeah yeah there's no there's
no grand master of blitz
that's a shame maybe that's going to be
a next thing that they
maybe maybe
[Music]
so it's kilian not silent
no someone says it's kilian
yeah or is it yeah but um i first read
it
sillian there there you go man
but it's killian yeah okay oh yeah
grandma
a bullet grandmaster
thanks a lot man thanks for the
contribution thoughts on nihal sarin
uh well he's uh he he's one of the
the younger prodigies india is offering
nowadays
and uh well great things are expected
from him so we'll see
we'll see what happens he could have
actually captured on g6
he could have he could have couldn't
yeah instead of playing
but now it's now it's no it's just weird
yeah now it's queen h6 but doesn't
really do anything
queen g6 yeah queen g6 now wins yeah
oh he didn't see the first time now yeah
yes
not even now black knows about it but he
says okay you didn't see the first time
you're
you're never oh he does okay maybe he
heard it i don't know
no no there's too big of a delay there's
like at least 15 seconds
nice idea louis i didn't i didn't see it
what was
lewis's idea yeah
why do all creation names last names end
with
each no no they don't actually
yeah let's say most of them do
but the reason behind it is just i don't
know
history man yeah it's just history
okay i said i'm gonna go a little bit
behind
let's check it out the game of medina
are are so good yes they are
yes they are we are going to do a nazi
saga
at some point yash kotari
who's the greater player well uh misha
is definitely the greater player but
uh when it comes to to actual magic on
the board
uh i think uh both tal and everyone
would agree
that uh that nez medinav was the
was the the true wizard
opinion on chess-based india oh they're
they're like
incredibly incredibly awesome they like
uh okay now now they're
uh i i would say they're struggling a
bit not not in terms of
content or anything like that but they
really they really do enjoy covering
live events
and they they do an excellent job at it
so
now the with the situation in the world
and everything they have to only stick
to online stuff
uh but other than that yeah they're
they're incredible at what they do
uh both uh shagger shocking and
[Music]
they're running it nice
i think they they even called it uh the
the chesapeake india
they called it their like their baby
what about dr lasker saga oh we we don't
have time for that
that would take us a couple of years to
finish kiwi master
thanks a lot man yeah he was like uh
could i maybe change the color of the
board
what would you like would you like a
nice green
and maybe red what what did you have in
mind
alaska was like the longest world chance
champion right
yeah 27 years
green would be good i i i'd have to
check i don't know if
leeches offers green
okay so black is very nice here
what about f4 thoughts on nakamura
milking a cow
oh oh an absolute uh i mean it's a gem
like youtube if if it wasn't available
online
it would be the one thing the internet
is missing
like i i only hope he knows uh what what
he was doing i
i just hope he wasn't like herding the
cow or anything
like hope he knew how to milk it i think
in his video actually
explained something about it but i i
don't remember what
he said like when he was reviewing like
this thing
oh like your video that's actually me
i've milked many a cow
eric h welcome to the to the hoodie guys
team welcome
uh there are there are no perks the
perks are only symbolic but uh thank you
thank you for joining
what what what is this so i saw
excellent
subscribers and hootie guys oh it's like
uh it's like uh
like there are five uh five like
clubs when you join the channel oh
yeah and uh then then you get like the
use then you have your name in color you
get like
uh like this you get a followers badge
so when it's a green
you've been following for a month then
it turns like i think reddish then you
it means that you've been following for
two months then it turns like
it's like a loyalty badge i think
they're mainly copying twitch
but you know okay i see and also you get
to use emotes
so far i only have five of them but it
said that when i when more people join i
will have more
so i think i can use like as many as i
want now so i will have to
make some of them hi mans welcome to
excellent subscribers man
who you guys are the best
yeah like you have misha smoking a cigar
here mm-hmm
there you go so you have u meadow chucky
misha and which is the fifth one
uh fifth one is i don't know
i don't know what's the fifth one like
there's there's
the uh seven emotes
seventy what seven emotes are there are
currently seven really
the color looks very old-fashioned uh
that's
that's what i was going for oh there's
pepe the frog
and there's ganon oh yeah i i use this
these ones just to try them out this is
ganon from zelda
he's our enemy and this is link when he
beats the game
he's holding the triforce although you
can't really see it so i guess
it's maybe a bit too small we're gonna
change that one
how did pepe the frog came into this
channel
uh it's uh well a lot of people were
using it uh during the park champs
championship
and i had no idea what it was and then
yeah
oh people explained it to me and i i
thought it was a nice one
okay
thank you for the contribution man she
was getting a lot of bad rap in the
past yeah no he still does uh
yeah but only i i think only in the
united states but
you know i mean you can use any symbol
for anything i mean yeah
true like someone can literally take
your face and use it as a symbol for
you know obliterating the mankind but
doesn't mean that your face is bad no i
agree i agree
yeah in over the board chest is it
possible to have timer built in
electronically when each player makes a
piece move
not use a clock timer of course it's
possible but
where's the fun in that i mean there's
some fun
making a move is enjoyable but actually
slamming the clock like there's
you can't put a price on that yeah
unless you're playing as a child against
uh
people who like to do it to actually
disturb you
and frighten you and maybe even kick you
under the table
yeah then it's a different thing yeah
are you thinking of the same person
as me i i don't know but i don't want to
say it out loud
ah make the chest clock that says ouch
when you hit it too hard
yeah that that might not be a bad idea
yeah people are overusing that
um okay let's check out
a game for example exotic camaro yeah
sure sure
for the longest time in first place
when did you play your first chess game
on
my first chess game i played when
i was in 5th grade which is
12 years old or 11 years old really
not before no i i actually started
pretty late which was sometimes said to
be a problem
because i didn't actually like reach any
title
you know because i started kind of too
late and i didn't spend too much time on
it you didn't have
uh tournaments to play yeah but yeah
that's that was it like i played against
my grandfather
he was the guy who actually told me how
to play yeah
and then grandfathers are like that yeah
they're into chess yeah yeah
yeah was it the same for you you uh your
grandfather taught you yeah but he
taught me when i was five
okay i just didn't play any any any
chess until
maybe even later like 16
when you came to the chess club no no
that was when i was uh
18 18 or even 19.
yeah yeah yeah i think that i'm not sure
if at that point i was
already in high school i don't think i
was i'm not sure i don't remember
no you weren't you were 12 12
yeah you were 12 then okay i was also
just starting
yeah but also you beat me in six moves
in the first game
yeah but it took some time for you to
yeah yeah kind of remember all the stuff
all right i like black here
not gonna lie yeah it's a good one not
gonna lie although that a pawn
is good but when you set up a battery i
don't know
yeah i mean the white's king is like out
of n out in the open so
i would play bishop g4 and then rook c2
carlo botta thanks
thanks for the contribution man what
about
pretty agarwal there you go man
are you some kind of a master jan are
you some kind of a master
um am i are you a master hiker master
hiker yeah you're a master hiker
definitely
what a very good position for for black
here
with two rooks yeah it is
oh you sent me uh the photo i forgot
about that
oh yeah why don't you remind me oh i
don't know all right so
after this game uh oh there's okay
there's more time in the tournament so
i'm just going to prepare
it so everyone can enjoy
so i'm guessing like this stream is
something that we didn't have before
some photo time with people okay i guess
that's misha and that's uh karish yeah
so me with hair as well
all right a little bit of beard going so
we're gonna call this uh
j1 and we're going to call this j2
although we don't have time we don't
have a room on the screen for both of
them
so we're just gonna show one and then
one all right so we're just gonna
show another game uh since our
tournament director isn't uh directing
goku all right goku double-oh-seven so
two things we we both like yeah
uh mr jeez
where the 71st uh but yeah
okay this game is starting out so we can
check that game out all right there we
go
and now we show uh which one do we show
first
your uh photo with misha or with
j1 is the first one but maybe we
start with the j2 huh okay all right we
start with j2 okay so this is jan
with paul kerris
there you go so we can check that out
very quickly
so this is in tallinn at uh not actually
in the center of the city but you have
to go a little bit out
uh founded on google maps actually
someone marked it
as a point so you can actually find it
if you're not from tallinn
okay so i was there in uh march
this year and this is like his signature
i'm not sure what it is
but it's there and it's kind of weird it
kind of reminded of
me of him but i wasn't too satisfied
with his statue
no no but it's much better than miesha's
oh that's
all right and here here's the one uh
with misha
there you go that's j one right
j one yeah j one all right and this is
jan
with misha that's a horrible statue yeah
so
like i said it's like they have this
head and they said like let's
use it for some some statue yeah and oh
and this is the
the official statue of misha in riga
yeah this is i should really improve on
this yeah they should improve on that
but you know it's still it's still nice
that you were able to visit
it uh it could be like a second mission
of this channel like the first one
making an edge medina with gm
yeah and the second one build a better
statue
for everyone yeah yeah also also a nicer
tombstone for for bobby fischer wouldn't
be a terrible idea have you seen that
uh actually no it's like really really
terrible
yeah like it's like uh it's like a
little bump
on the ground you know with with a
little bump
yeah yeah but literally like that let me
and it's some in some sort of a
construction yard or something
i mean last time i saw it look like that
isn't it in the graveyard
no no you think but no okay
okay no he didn't he likes to be alone
you know
but i thought like they really adored
him in reykjavik
yeah but i i don't think anyone like put
put up
the money or anything to make like a
like a decent tombstone or anything
yeah that's a shame yeah i mean
like at least space wow okay maybe it's
just me maybe i'm just expecting too
much but i mean
i've i've seen were much worse
you know people have much much better
tombstones
much worse people have better stem stuff
yeah not much worse but people who
i don't know i i would think a a world
chess champion deserves a nice tombstone
that's for sure
like it doesn't have to be a world chess
champ it could be a world like
any any champion i agree
but i i don't know maybe it's just me
okay uh i think you have to click on the
arrow
and the chess the the chat is not
loading
yeah i think so
yeah he died in 2008 at 64 years of age
uh yeah i might have missed one uh since
i was uh
enjoying that uh photo of jan
oh yeah he says you're a masturbator
there you go thanks hi man
am i going to make more educational
chess videos yes of course
those are the best those are the best
madu what's the best opening move you go
first
like e4 e4 of course yeah i mean
nothing compares i don't think i've ever
played a different one
me neither like in a classical game i
actually uh played against you in one of
the games knight f3 as a first move i
think
really yeah i do not remember that yeah
because i just wanted to avoid because
we played so many
games together just wanted to avoid a
classic
e4 c5 you know and then
yeah but i don't play c5 ah
what was that oh that was a uh
brilliant brilliant sneaky
oh yeah oh that was good i mean you
don't play
c5 anymore you played scandinavian now
right
would you deal uh now but now i've also
started playing the sicilian
i've i've done some work would you deal
with two knights or the bishop pair if
you mean
what i would rather play against uh well
it depends on the position and the time
format of course but
uh you know i i respected the bishop
pair
a lot although in the bullet or blitz
game two knights are the night pair is
also deadly
um we have a croatian clash
oh bruno dino
venki venky india all right we're gonna
play some hand and brain
and uh if you drop a challenge we will
we will try try and select you although
the selections are random
completely random well try to remember
wanky india okay okay good to know
thank you for the contribution uh tom
tom junetunen
[Music]
it's not on youtube but uh still i i
feel it's
it's nice to mention it use this flower
to give hikaru power
yeah i know that uh i know that uh
that's saying uh it's from the
it's from one of the streams but
motorino used it in one of our
one one of his videos okay
cronin is i mean black skin is
kinda opened up yeah oh
interesting it's gonna be interesting
where to move the queen yes
yeah queen e3 is a threat if you move
the knight
and then knight c3 oh it's it's going to
be crazy do you need some more not beer
i would definitely enjoy some more not
beer yeah the
the nakamura nakamura song that that's
the one
the diagon classic wait
is that like uh and the cartoon i got
matarina made
okay it's actually maybe that one i i
think
uh we we could show it if you haven't
seen it
i i don't think i got motorino would
mind
okay bruno won yeah bruno
bruno is like that he likes to win
is also in a good place
sharkboy 1300
oh we already saw a game by him oh
people and shook we didn't see a game
bike okay but let's move away from the
top 10.
it's important to to check out everyone
no no i agree i agree
like there's a raj metoon for example
okay we can check out raj
i always enjoy a game by raj yeah
[Music]
do i know i have been used to feed an ai
for reading lips
yeah i've seen that video yeah it's
actually a good one
oh uh but i can't remember who sent it
to me
uh but i'm gonna copy this link since i
totally forgot about it i think someone
sent it to me and i like saw it before
going to bed
and then i completely forgot about it
yeah i'm gonna just uh
put it here for future use there we go
dear fellow scholars yeah
two minute papers okay i'm gonna check
it out uh
afterwards you are in this video yeah
someone used my video to teach an ai to
to read lips oh really yeah okay
is that like a compliment or it's just
it was random
i i would say so yeah i would say so
okay
nice if i had a daughter do i think i
could
engineer her into a champion like the
polgars
i i don't think that would be possible
laszlo is a great mastermind for what he
achieved there
and also the the polgar sisters are
extremely talented so
you know i i'm i'm nowhere near
as good as a teacher as laszlo and i
have no idea if uh
if my genes would be you know
able to to create something like that so
i would say no but i mean it's uh
like it isn't just about the genes
thank you harsha thanks for the
contribution
yeah but it's like uh you know nature
versus nurture
yeah is it is it this is it that or is
it a little bit of both
uh best moments episode three is coming
right
after this stream like as soon as we
finish the stream
it's being published i i think so
i think i've uploaded it can't wait
yeah there it is there it is yeah it's
called agatha mata best moments episode
three
so pretty wild d11
thanks for the contribution man
oh man who is your favorite chess player
in history of chess like
i would assume the guy above your head
what jan or or mr barnes your head
ah misha yeah that's a good one
okay raj go faster
oh yeah another hikaru video coming then
yeah yeah
most likely
all right raj can you do this oh i
thought he berserked but he actually
didn't
no i mean raj was in a good position and
all of a sudden now
he has two pawns down don't know why and
have
has only 13 seconds on the clock
i'm just gonna quickly jump and go to
the bathroom yeah you know where it is
yeah so many indians in the chat uh what
do i say about that well i mean
chess is extremely popular in india so i
i i don't see that that's something
something weird
when will i play rook odds match against
magnus
i i i like to think i i could not be
beaten by anyone with rook odds maybe
that's just wishful thinking but i i
don't think i would
i could lose like with records maybe a
bullet game or like a three minute blitz
game but
or maybe a five minute blitz game but
yeah i don't i don't think
with records longer than that i i don't
think it's possible
i i could be wrong though
have i ever played a match against the
vichy no i i played one a game against
him but
as a part of an exhibition with the with
the
comedians on board
have i met agatha matorino only via
messenger
only via messenger but we had a we had a
good messenger meeting
definitely all right who do we have
next uh smartypants chess okay we lost
them powerx wisdom
okay this game is just starting out and
we have do we have it
oh yeah we have the
no yeah uh the the traxler attack i
believe
oh and we have the traxler in its full
glory
sub battle against hikaru uh to this day
i don't know what's a sub battle
is it a battle where subscribers battle
or is it a battle of who brings more
subscribers to the battle
how does it work
i got motorino don't ask someone to stop
spamming you you can
put him in a timeout that's uh that's
what a moderator does
teams of subscribers all right so it's
like a leeches team battle
uh rye morrison i don't know why youtube
uh hid
that message i think youtube
misinterpreted something
but uh although it's hard for me
uh to understand it also
has india overtaken us in the number of
subscribers on the channel
no it's still like the united states is
like over 30
and india is like second uh i think it's
around 13 percent now
uh fellas says hi
oh meadow what up nato
how are you doing meadow don't be greedy
we went for a walk just before the
stream
yeah that is the best made of the the
big dog
he's the only dog as well but
my favorite gambit in the history of
gambits oh
that's a hard one no it's not
everyone knows what what gambit is dead
the hungarian gambit of course
oh so you were discussing just now the
percentage of
the subscribers like uh globally
countries where they come from okay yeah
yeah okay i'm not a fan of the jerome no
because you're in a position where you
can play the evans gambit you you don't
play anything else like you don't play
the jerome gambit
if you're in a position to play the
evans jerome gambit
yeah it's like in the position where you
can go for b4 in the evans you
just play knight captures an f7 and it's
uh you know or bishop no a bishop
captures an f7 so it's
just uh okay kokob
welcome and hello to you sir as well
does this work at all like
this uh gambit like you did what did
taron say
a youtube feed shows a different
thumbnail for the chat for this uh
live which thumbnail is showing it's not
showing the one where
jan and myself are in
yeah it's about as playable as the bong
cloud although when you play the bomb
cloud and you win
you're the man indeed
power x wisdom power times wisdom
against martha of 1998
okay maybe it's a roman 10 power 10
wisdom
who knows i guess
this guy knows yeah
bonk clouding right now says ry morrison
a wonderland uh do we know of him or
about him
wha what about him
who won the 1958 candidates tournament
isn't it like 1959 yes it is it's a
trick
question we won the 1958
i don't know do you know
no there wasn't a tournament in nineteen
fifty
there's no candidates tournament every
year uh
even even before yeah it was every four
years back then
every four now it's every two yeah okay
how's alpha doing
i i imagine well no today now it's every
two years
before back then it was every four years
interesting or or something like that
maybe they switched it up a year here
and there
it seems that the power and the wisdom
are not helping in this game
this year leela won the tcc no this year
stockfish one
uh stockish one season 18 it's been a
while since stockfish won
okay let's see what's happening
is hasabi is the smartest person you've
ever met i
i don't think there's like a measurable
way of knowing that
but i'm sure he would qualify yes
sounded like a pretty good username so
i haven't heard of little misha ever
since his clash with uh
with uh anatoly but oh yeah i follow
him i follow misha on instagram uh he's
like you know doing
normal stuff not like jess anymore
uh i think he is but i don't think like
he's
only into chess
[Music]
it shows the thumbs up thumbnail
on my feed but on your channel is the
one with you and yan
oh so that's that's weird
uh yeah i don't know why i'm taking play
at oh i can play
ad wow that's mean wow
youtube greedier than usual and they
also have a create highlight
oh that's also something from twitch i
believe you can like create a moment
do people usually do that after the
stream
or maybe the thumbnail was not updated
yeah it could be that the thumbnail
wasn't updated but okay i i don't know
what does it mean slow mode is on
slow mode it means that once you write
something you can't write anything else
for 15 seconds
to reduce spam oh nice oh that's a very
smart thing yeah otherwise sometimes
it'd be like
like it'd be pretty crazy it's funny but
the thing that this guy wrote actually
somebody else said it to me
already really yeah this yeah
okay
but doesn't everyone look like one of
those
i mean they are quite uh i've never like
nobody told me that before so i don't
know but
probably it seems like it's a pretty
famous one yeah the
have you seen it now i know i know who
this guy is
okay yeah it's a pretty well he is a
pretty famous one
okay in that industry is that why you
shaved your hair
no no look more like him no no no there
was that wasn't the idea
okay carl strix won the game all right
congratulations
good one king pushkar do you need more
not beer
let me just take care of that oh caissa
keep in mind for the next stream when
i'm gonna be on it uh
if you have an interesting username at
least an interesting username to me
there's a very good chance that you're
gonna be featured
on the stream what do we have here
it seems like uh there's been more
commentating in one of the past streams
so let's try to do it a bit more now
why try to maybe give some sort of a
threat on the king side but black is
up a piece and it should be a fairly
easy game to win for black
from b2 where it rook e6 try to pick up
the pawn on f6
and go from there should be an easy game
but black has other plans let's see what
he does
so white is still there we go thanks
oh sorry we need to improve this uh
yeah okay it's friday arena now but
we're also going to add
mailman yeah i should have said i'm the
mailman
oh yeah definitely
again video that was a good one as well
there we go nicely updated jan is much
quieter
uh oh really there we go we're gonna
move the mic
more to yan i i thought like i'm not
talking as much
but that cannot be true storm of the
century best
uh game ever played hard to say but
one of my favorites definitely
that was a nice sacrifice oh no
it's interesting that kaiser just
no what no
no yeah about 40 42 seconds
uh to 27. yeah
you pick up some pawns but that's it
pretty much king 86 losing the game
will you be playing ghost of toshima
what's up what's a ghost of to shima
i'm not i'm not familiar with that
oh favorite movie do you know what's my
new favorite movie new favorite movie
that i told you what's my new favorite
movie
uh no but i can try and guess try i
guess uh
is it like a movie that you've only now
oh he
did not capture the queen uh okay
yeah but i think at this point it's
pretty much over
can you give one tiny and
inconsequential consequential spoiler
regarding best moments episode three
yeah sure but only only a tiny one
uh sorry that it was it a movie that
you've just recently seen
yes but is it like a new movie or an
older one it's a new movie
it's a new movie a newer movie it's from
2018 i believe
and it's your favorite movie it's
definitely my favorite movie yes
wow it's an amazing movie from 2018 i
think i stopped watching movies like
it's 2016 but
you should definitely watch this movie
what's uh what's the
first letter f f all right
2018 two words uh
is it someone's name no it isn't no it's
not all right so it's uh
actually uh it's actually a type of
um climbing to help you out
or the one with james franco no no no no
no
not that one not that one oh that's not
2018.
it's kind of a documentary like thing i
mean
that would james franco is that
considered to be a documentary because
no it didn't like yeah no but that's
like what's a biography
no no it's a normal movie based on uh
based on an actual event oh okay okay
okay
two words for mikhail batwinik uh
mission impossible six frozen two
[Laughter]
okay is there anything else there there
it is
there it is someone saw ah free solo
free solo that's right
yeah people knew because i'm probably
type of climbing
uh okay alex donald the best
man you gotta see this guy really good
good movie
guys is the movie really good i like i
don't know
for the people with a little mermaid no
it starts with an f
little mermaid
no free solo was just like man this guy
taron says it's wonderful
i don't think i could pick like a like a
best movie so i i don't think
there would be a best movie for me it's
always a thing of
uh like there's different types of
movies and depending on what people
want to see or like to see okay it's
always different
but for me like i didn't actually had a
favorite movie before this one
like that i would definitely like say
this is my favorite movie but when i saw
this movie
but it's also tied to the current
situation where i am in life and i like
hiking and mountains and everything and
when i saw this like what this guy is
actually doing
it's basically like free climbing he is
uh climbing uh like one of the most
dangerous places on earth to climb
but without rope and without safety oh
so it's
it is free climbing yeah i mean free
climbing
he explained it in the film because free
climbing and free solo are two different
things
oh okay yeah free solo is actually the
name where you don't have any safety
and free climbing is where you do have
safety even though it's
called free climbing i'm not sure about
the terminology i'm
not gonna i mean that's basically it the
movie
yeah yeah i'm not going to spoil it but
uh it's like
it's not about the actual you have to
see like his process and
everything like the movie is really
really good
okay someone says nelina nelina vasileva
says
i do rock climb okay
there we go we have some climbers in the
chat
do you have a favorite creation movie
favorite croatian movie yeah
i know i don't
[Laughter]
that's uh that's a good question i'm not
sure
i don't know uh free climbing you don't
use gear
for ascending to pull yourself up just
for protection free solo no protection
either
okay okay nicely done thank you for that
yeah thank you
panda yeah four two four seven yeah but
it's uh
i am i like that's like super difficult
like you have to have like
arms like a bear like to do that um
it's more about the the hands the
fingers
and uh the actual like so they
should be like really hard so because
you're always
going over this yeah that's of little
use if you don't have the muscles to
pull yourself up
sure and uh like the the main
exercise that this guy is doing is like
pull-ups
but not just regular pull-ups it's just
also with
like two fingers three fingers you know
no fingers
eye eyelids yeah you know
forearm and pinching power yeah
i mean i watched now like a bunch of
videos with the guy where he's
explaining the technique and everything
is just
like it's totally like uh
it's also a thing of this being totally
unfamiliar to me you know
oh someone says nothing starts with an n
and
ends with a g is that actually true
i accept the word nothing yeah oh yeah
oh that's a joke oh
nice nice yeah
but is it is not is it the only one
i'm pretty sure it's not yeah
will i ever analyze nikola charsovich
what's that like
279 moves is it is it
something like that i i don't think i
will good
i just might good job
crondana played a lot of games yeah okay
nagging and
that that's just adding the ing that's
not that's not what i was thinking i was
thinking like an actual word without
adding the ing
like we can obviously add ing to any
verb starting with an n
yes
hello neighboring yeah people are uh
people are throwing in verbs with an ing
but that's not
what we were looking for we need a noun
by pi yeah nothing has an ing but it's
not an
uh an added ing it's not a
north eggnog
yeah i'm sure there are all only there
like uh
nutmeg nutmeg is a good one yeah yeah so
so that neil young
nice
[Laughter]
that's a good one
[Laughter]
nice oh yeah okay all right what do we
have
we have a game in a car six more minutes
so we are uh
definitely going to check up on the top
ten after this
sure snowing good one yeah neil young
gopi
robert how how are things in ireland
nazgul
oh man ah the man from earth yeah
i'm a big fan of man from earth yeah
watch that movie yeah
i think i actually donated money to them
for making a third movie
but like i donated ten dollars on their
website and then
uh a photo pops up of all of them
together and they're like
thanks man like on twitch yeah but
like it's static it doesn't go away so
10
will be enough for the movie well it was
for part three
i don't know what they're doing uh but i
think part two of men on earth it's
meant on earth wholesome
and it's completely free but not like
free
that you can just download and watch it
you can act i could i could actually
play it on you on my youtube channel and
it would be cool
okay so it's it's completely free
so you know i also right so like uh
like it was set here i didn't know there
was a sequel i just knew
you haven't seen hults and no yeah and
they they said that
you know it's like i think it's like a
side project for those guys there
it's not like what they do so they're
they they might do a third part
but like i think if they yeah royalty
free
if they if they like make enough money
we could we could like maybe for uh
celebrating one million subscribers we
could do like a charity stream for them
to to make like the the part three oh
it's not like a super high budget movie
so i i think i don't think they like
need millions of dollars i mean
it's shot in one room
i think you know okay
i mean could be could be a noble thing
if uh if you're up for it why not yeah
all right that's a nice fork
yeah nicely forked nicely forked
it seems that black is
in a good position here oh
what about f4 king h7
interesting king h7 knight h4 g5
comelyn mung uh we're actually going to
play some uh some
hand and brain after the tournament
yeah second movie was in more locations
they were trying to
expand i think so
i don't know maybe maybe they're gonna
return to the one room in part three
have you been to bulgaria no i actually
have been
and i was playing chess in bulgaria in
2012.
what was it it was like the university
championship
ah okay yeah bulgaria is a very nice
country
it's very cheap you know yeah to buy uh
alcohol there so
good good stuff i mean that's like the
number one priority for a student
everyone to bulgaria yeah
i've only seen episode one of dark
uh i i haven't uh gone gone past that
i i i started watching the what's it
called the
the sinner now but uh i've seen season
one it's only eight episodes it was
pretty good i i'd say
avengers end game is the greatest movie
yeah no no it's not
yeah i'm actually a huge marvel fan but
no it's not
yeah uh like there are a bunch of these
movies that are like uh
very popular with a lot of people but
i mean when i would like to choose a
movie it's like this movie that really
like
shocks you to the core you know and like
really
surprises you and it makes you like
really think about stuff
you know it it's this thing that you
know that is special in a way
yeah i mean i i'm pretty sure like every
top
10 top 20 top 100 top 1 million places
like shawshank redemption as the
the greatest movie ever and while it is
great
i i don't think i would like put it as
my
my personal favorite yeah it's been for
the longest time the best movie on imdb
yeah but i mean followed by godfather
godfather
two yeah i mean they are both great
movies but
and one thing i don't understand that
the dark knight is also
like always in the top ten
dark nights or dark knight rises
i don't know something with the dark
knight
what are the the sequels so
dark dark knight begins i think his
batman begins no
batman oh batman begins and darkness
okay
was a good movie yeah i mean it was but
i mean was it that good
i wouldn't say so yeah
yeah interstellar i i love movies like
that and i love mcconaughey but
uh interstellar was just too too weird
for me
and i like weird
yeah oh back to the future of course
seventh seal yeah the only thing bad
about seven seal
is that the chess game that the they
actually play
is not an actual game i mean they just
uh because they have the
they shot the board from here and then
when they switched
scenes they just you know scramble the
pieces they didn't
continue the game so it was very sad
oh it seems that we're gonna end the
tournament soon so prepare
all right so it's three two one and we
uh these gentlemen will not be getting
any points or will they
maybe just in time maybe but okay
exotic camaro who was actually in first
place for the longest
uh yeah duration how did he play so many
games
a lot of berserk yeah a lot of berserks
yeah so you can see that uh you know
quantity counts 97
berserks compared to coronel only 10
oh yeah so first place exotic camaro
congratulations on winning the
tournament over a thousand players uh
a thousand and one hundred and fourteen
players followed by
a coronal uh or corona
ill we don't know which one it is uh
followed by in third place uh
eric inning or is it
a eddie craining could be something like
that
grinding no i don't think it is
uh bruno again in fourth bruno always
starts strong and then
he's like always almost up there but
look at this
at second third and fourth 70 points
yeah yeah oh that's crazy oh bruno
that's
that's tough man yeah followed by uh aji
good
one two three uh sumaid the god uh
uh ravier h
envy followed by feeding master rana
rice
uh shattuck and daniel c87 and we're
gonna
call read out the the top 20.
so it's diaspora lb uh object virat 45
a frequent follower of the of the
tournaments and channel
uh walmer uh itpv veer
itp veer from india pipanchuk also
i think he plays in every tournament
smartypants chess i haven't seen
uh him uh from england uh
uttar kharnath
1300 so those are the top 20
congratulations everyone
and now i guess we can accept some
challenges
with some nice hand and brain action i
actually never played it myself
no no i mean me either so
gonna be interesting uh so please only
uh
casual games okay how are we gonna do it
so
i'm telling you the piece and you're
playing the move
i think we can switch every game okay
so it doesn't really matter yeah it
sounds good
leslie says challenge sent all right so
we're gonna
i know we have veki india or something
yeah we're not
uh okay we're gonna uh go with leslie
uh a long time follower on youtube and
on twitch both
so let's accept that all right so it's a
three minute game so if you're the hand
and i'm the brain
uh then you can play uh okay
if you go below 30 seconds then it's
just hand so it's
now it's my turn okay pawn
all right pawn
pawn
all right night
so interesting all right very nice
knight
maybe 94. maybe pawn
that's good that's good yeah three
minutes is plenty
all right pawn let's make it interesting
okay born i just want to say pawn
as many times as possible
all right pre-move bishop next pre-move
bishop yeah
i didn't made it in time yeah okay
uh okay a lot of possibilities now uh
let's see what he plays we're doing
better on time which is good he played
a3 yeah smash uh let's go rook
yeah it's the pawn storm a bishop
pre-move pawn
[Laughter]
no okay it actually kind of worked
you played g3 okay you don't actually
have to pre-move when i say pre-move
yeah
okay porn
that's very very interesting i think
we're looking quite good actually
okay i'm still gonna go with uh
i'm gonna go with with with just uh
with the just bishop it's just bishop
yeah for this one
yeah pre-move pawns are op we're gonna
pre-move as many as possible
all right uh yeah let's go rook
nothing wrong with rook i know you're a
pawn grabber okay
you know me well so i know you're a good
grabber
all right so now our options are
limitless limitless
we can do anything like there's that
there's that there's that
i'd go with queen queen yeah queen
okay looks good looks good we we kind of
prevent
castling and you know we don't need the
queen there
[Music]
yeah stockfish is also upon grabber and
a much better player than we are
come on man
oh that's a nice one what do we do now
i say we go for we go for
oh we go for queen oh yeah
okay
that's a good one that's a good one
so now anything is possible
very good very good
i'm gonna say i'm gonna say i'm gonna
say pawn
that's a good that that's a good looking
pawn
yeah that's a bit spicy all right
uh i'm gonna say i'm gonna say
i'm gonna say bishop um
okay
oh we're getting lower on time okay
nothing to worry about
uh yeah we go pawn we go pawn
we we got nothing to worry about
queen obviously next move unless he
captures with the knight
uh so we're gonna go with pawn
there we go you we we kind of blundered
the queen but it doesn't matter we're
too strong
[Music]
if he spots it it's cool good for him
yeah
a tasty snack yeah
alright so i think we're doing well
especially on time oh
[Music]
that's nice king
there we go
just to be safe yeah oh
nice that's nice that's nice i'm gonna
go with bishop
bishop to the rescue
not great okay so now obviously
i can go alone or oh yeah you can play
now it's it's below 30 seconds yeah okay
so it's gonna be oh immediately for the
queen trade
that's that's okay
[Music]
oh safety first safety first
oh he's oh he actually gives it up
not h pawn first to deliver mate
oh it's gonna be crazy one second on the
clock
one more what there we go
oh he's a good pre-mover he's a good
pre-mover yeah
all right that was a good one okay now
now we reverse
all right no funny stuff
king king king yeah like pawn and then
king
uh all right which one do we have let's
uh it's three minutes fine
all right i got motorino is challenging
to a five let's do this
let's do this he did create the the best
moments
for for when we finish the stream okay
night night all right let's let's do it
there we go
oh challenge accepted
fun all right challenge accepted
pawn all right
queen
immediately with with the grab uh queen
all right
there we go pawn
um night night all right
there we go there's a knight
which country is most addicted to chess
that's not
not an easy one bishop bishop i this is
a bishop
it is indeed um
[Music]
night night all right sounds looks a bit
greedy but okay
knight alright there we go
bishop all right
[Music]
interesting
bishop
oh bishop that's nice
uh yeah let's just go all the way back
there we go so now that he captures
bishop the bishop
sometimes when i uh when i was making
fisher videos i would say
bishop instead of fischer sometimes you
have to say fisher's bishop and then
it's like
what bishop come on brain
bishop okay no i mean that's just
that's just crazy um i'm gonna say
you're gonna queen oh i actually thought
you were gonna say bishop
but that's cool so yeah okay i know what
you want me to do but i'm not doing that
that's uh that's super boring yeah we're
gonna go for this
yeah but that's what i wanted oh i
thought you were go to the exchange
[Laughter]
yeah fisher bishop oh let's see um
queen seriously yeah
[Laughter]
you are one crazy dude i thought you
were gonna
castle and then just pound
but that works i guess um bishop
that'll work queen
queen is that a queen that's a queen
queen queen again we do have other
pieces you know
but you cannot the long castle because
of the bishop yeah i know
all right so if it's the queen
you seek uh we have
infinite time so that that works well
for us
all right let's just put a queen check
queen all right let's eat eat up
everything
we're hoping for a dark square yeah
that's true
oh okay all right rook
rook i think this is a rook
um queen queen
that's a queen and queen
and queen all right we were able to do
it
this was a this was a much cleaner one
this was a much cleaner one
i would say but i got motorino really uh
you know gave us
a nice challenge he played king e2 on
the second move
so that's uh oh do we want to play
against bruno
sure let's take bruno all right so now
uh
i'm the brain yeah yeah all right pawn
really fun
pawn knight
and of course pawn
uh bishop king
knight really there
all right bishop
uh rook
yeah bishop again
oh he bruno gave us a second thanks
bruno
um i'm gonna play here okay
okay pawn
what what next
uh this this crazy crazy mod
all right so what's that queen b3 let's
go
let's go let's go let's go pawn
i do like a good pawn push
[Music]
uh what is that bishop doing there
this one yeah okay let's go queen
pawn
let's go hmm it's interesting
let's go pawn
very nice very nice i think we're doing
very well
we're better on time
at night that's definitely good
oh nicely placed in the center
and now we wanna do something special
so we're gonna go
what are we going to go we're going to
go
we're gonna go bishop
yeah i didn't like that bishop there
okay
pre-move rook freeman broke unless he
does something crazy of course
then don't pre-move yeah
yeah i think i think that's what we want
to do
oh panda no we're not playing that
we could but there there's time we're
we're trying to beat bruno on time
rook here we go
yeah what's that he's gonna jump here
okay
so we're gonna play bishop
jonah thank you for the contribution
jonah
what do you think about the mo leicester
opening oh it's two
it's it's too abusive too abusive yeah
indeed
uh all right what do we have here rook
here all right
um let's uh go for a nice uh
let's go for a pawn yes
yes let's let's exploit his weaknesses
oh all right well i guess we go with
queen
queen yeah knight yeah of course night
okay uh i i don't know why i said queen
when
obviously i meant night
so it's a bit unclear what bruno is
trying here yeah hey hirishi
vowel welcome to excellent subscribers
man
evanesco you already played man
but we might accept it i don't know it's
up to yan yan is the tournament director
bruno some seconds give bruno some
seconds yeah where do i do that here
yeah all right
now let's go bishop
so good that's a good bishop move let's
go night
okay now we just don't care anymore uh
okay we we have time so let's go
let's go pawn
that's the stuff okay that's that stuff
taunting yeah daunting
all right let's go night
slowly but surely improving the position
of our knights
knight
[Music]
yeah that's a nice oh bishop obviously
and now it's really questionable all
right
that was a good one that was a bit of a
blunder by bruno there
but we were able to do it you choose
or uh no i have to go replenish
okay but i am the brain now
yeah um so the first one is
okay i mean evanesco we can play against
ivanesco
but i'm not going to accept it until you
come back so that we can start
uh
immediately
it's very interesting so okay
it's a very interesting uh form of play
yeah
oh you have to get this up
what no you just uh uh what you want
ivan
again but he didn't play against us no
no no no no oh just you played against
him right
no no we wanted to show his game but in
the end we didn't
ah okay okay uh so you're the brain
yeah all right brain man pawn let's go
okay i have no idea how this is played
night
night born
all right okay nice
all right uh pawn
all right are you saying you do not like
this
bishop no i i
just say that i don't know how this is
played you can't know it doesn't exist
oh uh bishop bishop all right
looked our bishop here from hell bishop
all right let's do this
king king there we go
[Laughter]
[Music]
night night night
all right there we go
doing good work here
bishop bishop
bishop
yes that's what i'll play
bishop bishop all right
[Music]
that's a nice one exploiting
our only weakness no it's not really our
only weakness but it is
bishop bishop
greedy greedy i like it i like it
oh bishop
i'm assuming you were going for the rook
yeah
pawn
there we go
all right oh
that's nasty insta
insta resigned
choose choose your destiny okay so
let's uh you know who says choose your
destiny in with your game
that's a question for the chat not you i
don't think you played that
okay you are the brain yes i am
so let's hear it let's go for the pawn
oh i like that i like that
mr e 2001 let's go bishop
yeah that's mortal kombat yeah yeah it
is
yeah let's go for pawn
yeah yeah mortal kombat
all right bishop pre-move knight
no
i'm sensing e5 oh what's that
sorry do we do we go phone grabbing
yeah we do bishop so this
hey david healthy welcome to excellent
subscribers man
you played uh yeah bishop of course
the belgrade gambit the absolute best
the absolute best
it's the gambit that the god that won uh
misha taught
his grandmaster title against the yuri
averbach
oh he goes for that a knight knight is
good
okay so we got a pawn i think we can be
happy
uh bishop yeah
it's a you know sn snatch and go
the what gambit the the belgrade gambit
it's the the only way to fly let's go
pawn
all right that that pawn will do as well
what is that lo lo gets
uh oh yeah let's go pawn
let's go knight
or this knight or that or that let's go
rook
yeah that's reasonable let's go rook
okay i'm guessing rookie seven is
another question england soul soul
thanks for the contribution man how
about a match with chess hater one
avenge your loss from two weeks ago on
stream
look for my challenge please all right
sounds like uh sounds like a fair deal
okay uh pawn
ah you're afraid of the light square
bishop
you played a pawn
yeah that's the one
all right so what do we have here oh
looks good but we're not worried
we're not worried let's go night
yeah for safety
all right so i think we can be very
happy here
this is okay yeah oh
let's go bishop let's kick that bad boy
away from there rook
even though it's the only move you can't
play it on your own
uh rook
i mean porn
and rook he has no time to be grabbing
pawns oh rook
could have played knight c6 though so
when the rock was here yeah
uh king king obviously
yeah good thing we have a knight on f8
otherwise yeah
otherwise none of this hap is happening
all right uh i would say rook
that's a nice one
huh oh rook rook
definitely rook oh this is one one uh
collecting rook
he like collects everything
okay so that queen is really in deep so
queen
okay but no i was actually going for
check
but okay no because oh [ __ ] okay
now now i'm on my own i was confused a
bit okay okay
but okay i think i'm good no it's not
the bravest rook the bravest rook
everyone knows who the bravest rook in
chess history is
yeah you're good if you don't lose on
time
and this is a rated game you have to win
so we don't lose rating
this is a rated game yeah oh so be quick
no it's a casual
nothing better than an accidental
checkmate
come on man i saw that no you didn't
oh oh okay can i control shift t
yeah okay ah okay
uh now who do we say we are gonna
challenge uh
i think it was chess hater but i don't
see him so we were that good i could
have blundered
all right chess hater let's do this oh
he challenged a five plus two
but it's okay so now okay
uh night night all right
there we go night night all right
night all right
oh nice
um
night
oh man no but it's looking good uh you
know
two nights early in the center of the
board i mean that's what uh
what people are hoping to achieve like
late game we already have it
kind of good yeah so i i think we're
good here
interesting why the heck was the nike
develop on the side
oh we are we're kind of mixing it up
following chess principles
all right night night that's a good move
that's a good move
so we baited the queen that's something
all right so what do we have
all right we're doing well on time
that's the only thing
yeah that's the night pair from hell
exactly indeed
exactly
all right
did i hear the joke about the chessboard
and nakamura
no but it's more than welcome
yeah let's let's hear it we're up for
some nice jokes
yorcha says he was 131st in the end
although he started very strong yeah he
was
looking pretty good queen all right
queen i
see i see what you are doing
uh well currently there aren't any vda
tournaments you can enter to start your
chess journey
why we chose a weaker opponent this is
not a weaker opponent
this is an opponent who who won our
previous tournament
do not be fooled by his rating that he's
a smurf
[Laughter]
all right i i thought you might say that
pawn pawn all right
uh pawn really
bomb
bishop all right maybe a bit too
ambitious but
we will try and make it work
i like how we're always doing better on
time
so fast queen yeah we have to do this
uh thoughts about anish geary streaming
on youtube channel
well uh it's uh it's very nice i would
say
but did he do it yeah yeah he's
streaming every day he
he started the youtube channel and he's
uh
enjoying himself very much king king
we're gonna go with this
i like how i've seen the i've seen his
stream i think it was like two days ago
where he played the bullet
he played bullet and then he had this
whole philosophy on how to tweet and how
not to tweet like first when you think
of a tweet you have to
disregard it because you know you get
very emotional
when you know magnus writes something
about him and then he gets emotional
fun pawn yeah and then he wanted to do
uh like really yeah
he wanted to really like cool the
emotions and then
uh write something insulting but that
it's not like
outright insulting like how to insult
someone without using actually insulting
words
so it was a it was a very deep stream
okay
night night night
night really yes you're you're that kind
of a dude
yeah will i ever do that
video yes i will actually prepared it
and i
uh i really prepared some really awesome
lines
uh but then i lost them so i will have
to
prepare it once again but i do know
mostly what i'm gonna talk about so
i will do it
i'm not touching this pawn that's for
sure
you threw a boomerang a few years ago
keep at it it might might return
play like barnes yeah um
i'm gonna say
it's an interesting position oh yeah but
we don't want to lose too much time
let's try and play
oh you now live in constant fear yeah i
imagined
let's play a rook
rook
okay all right
is there something to be done here there
most certainly is
uh king uh i'm sorry i did not i
i missed the joke yeah me too yeah plea
please write it again
both croatian croatians indeed
um yeah i see it
let's try
beshop bishop yes
okay very
very nice do i discuss chess games with
john at the bar
or the library of course but uh now
after the
morphe saga and all the barnes games
offline
no what
oh leech is also offline what
no seriously
still going so well oh no it's
reconnecting
lag yeah it does say lag but i think
we're we're back now
are we back oh it uh
it actually reverted your move with the
bishop so please
uh yes something uh something went uh
crazy but i don't know what
uh let me just check yeah there's a
there's like this huge lag but okay
we're gonna we're gonna fix that as soon
as we
no i think we've actually fixed it it
says video output low but
uh things being laggy
oh it repeated okay okay we're gonna
we're gonna play an ad break
no we're gonna technical difficulties
yeah all right
um yeah that internet provider i mean
seriously porn what
born yes oh he pre-moved that
actually all right
it's not the greatest of positions for
us but what are you gonna do
yeah i see it are you waiting for 30
seconds so i play
um i'm gonna say
yeah it's a difficult one indeed it is
pawn pawn
yeah uh oh i mean sorry without that
goes without saying
yeah yeah i think we are lagging i think
the internet service provider said those
are those moves are complete garbage you
will not be streaming today
nakamura tried to play a game on
chessboard but board didn't want to get
milked
oh okay i can see what you did there
let's play
knight
i like how you did that
all right very nice rook
nicely done
rook
[Music]
uh we are oh it's equal material yeah
wow
it's actually turning out to be a pretty
wild game
ah the um yeah we're now with all the
morphe saga
look we're actually calling it the the
barns and the library
it's no longer the bar in the library
jan versus the dodo the engine boy next
video
oh dodo has no equal yeah
it'll be a pretty short game yeah all
right
a rook
nice yes if you study the end game it's
pretty self-explanatory
[Laughter]
brag
oh it's a five plus two so we yeah we
get time
nice then maybe with me braining
around yeah i can reach oh you're seeing
chats from ten minutes ago
all right rook yeah you could have said
primo rook
supreme brooke all right
prima brooke okay premium rook
rook okay ah let's go here
will he see it yeah rook rock okay
not a problem oh rook oh
yeah he saw it he saw it okay good game
yeah so we
we were able to get our revenge uh
produce barnes merch oh yeah that's
definitely coming
can you do it the barnes merch yeah yeah
of course
we already have it there it is
[Laughter]
all right uh so no we we almost never
play with increment but
with uh with the hand and brain stuff i
guess it's actually
useful yeah it is i mean
all right dion you are free to choose
okay so if you are the tournament
director
let's go with three to make it more
interesting okay
okay brain oh we're first okay
pawn again with
the with the pawns
uh bishop pre-move pawn
all right bishop
pawn
uh let's see if he goes for the bait
uh knight
all right king and then we go
pon pawn knight pre-move pom pom knight
pawn
ah okay you prefer to do it like that
all right so let's go night
oh you you are a masturbator yeah yeah
okay so i guess spawn i mean if it's
free it's free
it's not really free so i guess bishop
what's the difference between jan and
jan
i guess the letter is different yeah i
guess the the knight
oh really there yeah why not okay
let's go rook and
pre-move pawn
pre-move pawn yeah i mean oh you can't
pre-move anymore because he already
played
here that's the only pawn i did not want
to play
[Music]
pawn there we go
uh yeah i guess i guess uh king
force that dude away yeah
i'm gonna force king
jonah thanks thanks for the contribution
man
yeah all right so what do we have here
i say pawn
that's a good pawn that's a good pawn
uh i'd say
i'd say pawn i'd say
night
i mean if it's offered we will take it
yeah why not yeah
now everything becomes possible
oh leslie you started playing chess uh
only six
year six months uh after seeing my video
okay maybe maybe you can even start
playing zelda who
knows uh wow queen d6
let's go let's go something wild
i would say i would say night
super wild yeah
[Music]
uh okay i would say queen
time to bring her into the game
the bishop
that's the stuff looks good
that's the stuff
all right so now everything is possible
we're not doing great on time but
so i'll have 30 seconds to finish oh i
think we'll win before that
but we'll see let's try let's try
oh he played we play what queen there
okay uh let's go let's go bishop
we need to
yeah we need to save it for later that's
uh that's that's one of the good guys
uh i wanna say pre-move knight
all right remove knight all right
yeah um
go for queen yeah
me
[Laughter]
yeah i'm not really sure yeah yeah it's
good enough
yeah it's it will do
oh well obviously night
and now go
yeah go pawn pon pong okay now it's me
but okay because you already tried
capturing it without me saying
oh okay oh but yeah it was you it was 30
seconds you could have captured it
is this the same friend who left chest
and became a librarian
yeah but a librarian hiker so not
not just a librarian oh you did it like
that okay
makes sense
all right uh i would say i i'd say you
have this
i'd say you have this
how are you still alive
no one won a game without pre-moving yan
[Music]
yeah i mean we would gladly play the
evans gambit if people played
something like that
are you trying to flag him or not sure
okay
[Laughter]
yeah of course he gave up just to become
a librarian hiker slash
former chess player i give up just to
become a former chess player
yeah that's like
you you can instantly accomplish that
yeah
that's my main goal all right so we
we play one more and i guess that's it
since there's uh some lag to the stream
yeah all right so who who is the final
challenge
man we are unbeatable in this brain
yeah even even bruno couldn't tackle us
yeah
it's pretty crazy uh all right
uh let's i want to play someone who we
still haven't played
okay uh most of them are
who we still haven't played
yeah we can't get the dog in the video
he's always in the video he's behind jan
he was in the video no but he's always
in the video oh now you scared him
no no he's here he knows him um
when you see john he comes all right
looking for
an interesting one uh gigamish
gigamish okay sure all right gigamish
sounds good sounds like gilgamesh
all right let's do this pawn
pawn i know you're a big scandinavian uh
enjoyer yes that's why all right
mix it up meadow came to join us for the
final game
yeah uh who is the brain in this in this
game
i think meadow is the brain yeah man
what do you want to do
in the scandinavia let's go for the
center yeah
so just porn
i i think some some some people think
you are dodo
did you say pawn yes
okay not the night
let's go all the way light
seriously
okay uh oh e5
the dream bishop
all right let's go here
looks very interesting yeah meadow is
the real brains behind the channel
that is true
king
i know gilgamesh
all right but it's not gilgamesh's
gigamish
bishop
bishop all right let's let's make it
interesting
oh dude you want to lose the last game
let's make it interesting
that's that's the stuff
we have to play like barnes everything
everything in development
okay pawn
uh pull on
yeah we have to make it as interesting
as possible he kind of helped us out
here so
he did he did he didn't want to go for
the rook
yeah he's not though dota is at home uh
training for the next dc season
he's making little engines all right
queen yeah
i think i think it's just the best
nothing better than this
all right young looks
guilty af might steal your meadow
no no ian loves dogs but not
that much that he would steal one yeah
at night there we go
the blue man is a nice guy and his laugh
sounds like ford
like like the car maybe like allen ford
although how do you know what his left
sounds like
no that's true not sure maybe maybe
henry ford
like you know the the man behind
ford night
uh night
are you sure most definitely
are you sure you wanna go night yes
no there's no question about it okay
give me an icon okay
that's good i like him actually one of
my favorite formula one
drivers so
uh he is the one that came after
hakkinen
yeah yeah he kind of
like was the next finnish guy after him
okay
all right everyone lives likes kimmy
that is true
yeah that's what i heard all right so i
would just
grab that whatever needs grabbing
yeah i mean the knight i would just grab
that would you
yeah of course yeah it seems like a good
night
uh if he doesn't want to take it then
we'll take the rook
right okay fair fair gigamish
please beat grab these knights
oh okay um where do we go
rook okay it doesn't matter oh yeah
yeah i thought about this rook but
i don't think it will play a big role
night yeah okay
bishop bishop oh my dutch
really bishop yeah
there we go what what next
rook rook all right you wanna you wanna
go something like this
indeed rook there we go
rook okay queen
here we
that's oh go won on time okay
but that was yeah okay guys so that's
uh that's it for this stream
congratulations to the winners of the
meadow arena and also of the yaga
matters friday arena
and to everyone who who played us uh in
the hand and brain
maybe for the next tournament we'll try
one without the arena just uh you know
three hours of hand and brain it seems
that's a good one yeah it's uh
seems pretty enjoyable yeah so at least
to us
hopefully for you as well i i do hope so
so yeah
uh thanks everyone and uh we'll we'll
see you guys soon
uh we are publishing the uh next episode
of agad matar's best moments as we speak
now
so publishing it in three two one and
it's published
there you go it's not published yet it's
published now
there we go i can't wait to watch it all
right so
that's it guys enjoy the episode and
share it with your well
friends at the barnes and the library of
course
later guys enjoy bye